over the years teaching people to trade
I have learned how to make people as
profitable as fast as possible stopping
people from wasting years trying to
figure it out on their own and in this
video I have condensed everything I know
about trading so you can Master it in
one video I'm going to show you the
strategy I wish I knew as a beginner the
biggest Discovery I ever made trading
that drastically changed how I approach
trading the market today how I find key
supply and demand zones Candlestick
secrets that I've learned along the way
and also how to start and grow a small
account into a big one the most 15
impactful trading tips I have and then
the reality of what trading really looks
like and then of course how to become
profitable as fast as you can none of
this will work though if you don't focus
on the most important factor and that is
focusing on one simple strategy so today
I made a little over $1,600 day Trad let
me break down exactly what that strategy
is I'm going to break down how I read
the market what patterns I'm looking for
how I enter into the market and how I
manage to trade once I'm in it so after
this video you will be able to know my
exact strategy and be able to know how
to execute it yourself so every trading
day I start with looking for the key
areas of support and a resistance and so
what that is is looking at a larger time
frame chart than what I trade and just
looking to the L side of the chart with
the market currently trading down here
what I want to be looking for is because
we're in a downtrend I want to look for
key support Zone to see potentially
where the Market's going to bounce
Market's bounce here multiple times if
the market comes down here again there's
pretty clear support level down there so
after I identifying the key areas to
look out for i' like to jump into a
smaller time frame chart and just wait
for the market to come to those levels
because when it comes to trading you
don't want to be reactionary and trying
to fit to what the market is doing you
want the market to fit to your plan
that's the best way I found to become
profitable and so let me walk you
through a few key steps that I look for
when looking for these reversals now I
really only look for reversals and do it
based on looking at a 15-minute chart
for the levels and a 1 minute chart for
actually trading and so what I actually
trade is the S&P 500 futures and they
give you about 450 times leverage which
allows you to start with a really small
account and get a lot of movement
potentially and then I just read the
candles and you can really read any
Market you want and so if you want to
trade on a different time frame
different Market you really can so the
first thing is is getting to this
support level the second is making sure
that the downtrend into this level is
broken and it's lost Steam and so if you
just kind of look at this in general you
can see that the Market's kind of
trending down here trending down and all
of a sudden it's just kind of going
starting to go sideways and so that's
pretty clear that it's starting to lose
steam now the trend could start to
continue lower and break this support
level or could just kind of go sideways
or or it could you know start going up
and so we want to try and identify when
it's going to start going up and so we
can jump in and capture that move and so
the key things that I found that really
help identifying that is well one what
we have in this trade is that the market
is almost making what I like to call
exhaustive moves and so what that looks
like is you can see it's making attempts
to push lower twice here and they're
starting to get rejected so it made an
attempt to go lower here and it got
rejected and then you know the mark kind
of just chopped around and so that just
shows you indecision and then the market
again does this a second time where it
makes an attempt to keep going lower and
it's attempting to push that downtrend
lower and start the trend again so once
I see this exhaustive move I want to see
the market lose that momentum because if
it loses that momentum it's likely to
shift higher and I like to think about
my strategy as it's a domino effect and
so if I see a you know a smaller
downtrend like this it start to go
sideways well if that shifts well if we
think about it there's the larger
version of that as well where there's a
little downtrend here sideways and if
this breaks it can make a really big
shift higher and so the thought is if
this little guy shows that as well it
can trigger this big one to go higher
and so that's how I like to jump in I
look at the big picture the big picture
is the most important but to get kind of
a super accurate entry this is how I do
it and and so the final thing here is
seeing that the market makes a head and
shoulders pattern really just looking at
these swing lows is seeing that as the
market you know moves in this downtrend
is the swings get lower and lower in a
downtrend and then to go into an uptrend
the swings generally start to get higher
and higher and so if this theoretically
is going to start into an uptrend the
swing lows will get higher and higher
and so that's what I'm kind of seeing
right here and so my thought is okay
this is a big red Candlestick that shows
a lot of momentum lower but it's
immediately rejected by this big green
Candlestick and so I think that's a good
confirmation that the market is likely
to potentially start to reverse and so
what I do is I take actually indicator
I've made that just tells me how many
contracts I need to trade to hit a
certain risk and so I like to at the
moment I'm risking about 350 per trade
and so what that does is this just
calculates exactly how many contracts I
need to trade in so this says I need to
put in 32 contracts to risk $350 if my
stop loss is right where this red line
is and so then it also shows you where
one times two times or three times my
risk is so you know up here 3 * 350 you
know so that's about $1,050 in profit if
I'm right and the market goes all the
way up here and so there I jumped into
the trade I actually filled 28 contracts
because I didn't get as good of a price
I wanted and that's totally okay what
I've done in the past is I've tried to
you know get a better price with a limit
order because you know you think well if
I get down here you know up here is like
five times my risk reward or six times
or it doesn't have to move as far to hit
three times and that's totally true but
you don't know what the Market's going
to do after your signal shows up you
know it could just Skyrocket right away
and so what I found the best thing to do
is just get in once you see the signal
You Can't Always Get the best price you
know and so you have to just let things
play out and go from there now to just
kind of show you how this trade went
briefly is I like to actually manage my
trade and you can see I'm kind of moving
my stop- loss I had it here now I moved
it to break even cuz the Market's kind
of all over the place and my thought is
okay it's starting to show that momentum
and if it goes in my favor great but if
it comes back down the Market's been
really choppy overall and so I kind of
just want to get out of the trade at
that point if it goes against me but
once you know we kind of get going here
it works out really nicely in my favor
and so once I hit about three times my
risk I switch to a very tight trailing
stop loss and so here we're about I
don't know four times my risk five times
we risk we're pushing and so I just go
to the previous Candlestick because the
market can move really fast in your
favor like you're scene and watching the
number change is very very emotional and
so I jump out quickly if it's moved up
quickly my favor because as you can see
right here it's come back very quickly
the market likes to have these rubber
band moves and so they're awesome if you
can get in them catching it but you have
to get out quickly if it's going going
to reverse back down on you take a look
at all of these charts every chart has a
reversal here and what do all these
charts have in common every one of these
reversals happens around 7 a.m. in the
morning allowing it to be something that
you can consistently repeat every single
day with confidence this is a strategy I
have recently discovered myself where I
go into every morning around 7: a.m. and
look for a reversal to happen it's so
consistent that once you go into every
trading day with this plan you can
consistently be profiting off of these
reversals when the market comes down
look for a few key steps that we're
going to go into and then you can
capture really nice clean reversals
potentially every day now after finding
this timing trick I narrowed down my
trading to only trading a a couple of
hours a day and it has been allowing me
to trade a short amount of time and
still capture really big reversal trades
and make more money than I was before in
a shorter amount of time now the first
thing about this is it doesn't have to
be exactly at 7:00 a.m. you can see this
trade I entered in 20 minutes after that
timing but the whole idea is around this
time the market starts to reverse what
I'm focusing on is the NASDAQ futures
the es Futures and oil Futures
essentially what these are is the S&P
500 the NASDAQ and the oil market and
you can trade those with options stocks
and even shares sometimes now I trade
Futures because they can give you 4 to
500 times Leverage The Leverage can be
insane you can start really really small
with under $500 and it allows you to go
in every day and find find potential
reversals like this even at a smaller
account like this trade now keep in mind
these times are the US market time so
for me I'm in the Pacific Standard Time
and so I'm on the west coast of the US
and so the US Market opens for me at
6:30 but the normal US market time for
Eastern standard time this is actually
9:30 a.m. in the morning that that's
when it opens and so then the timing for
that is 30 minutes after the open and
the whole reason why this works is what
happens is the Market opens here let's
say this is the S&P 500 right now it
opens up at 6:30 and often times the
market has Jitters in the morning for
the first half hour it'll move around
and potential news will come out a lot
of Times News comes out 15 minutes after
the open or at 7 half hour after the
open and so this causes the market to
potentially run up into that news and
reverse the price of the market and so
if a couple of the factors that we're
going to talk about show up you can look
for a potential reversal and a lot of
the times is what can happen is this
sets up the move for the day is where
right here you can see is on this day
the market opened up it made a fake
higher it attempted to continue we had
an uptrend on the left side going into
this day it kind of had a pullback and
then it attempted to continue higher and
instead what happens is the Market makes
that fake higher the news pops and comes
out and instead around 7:00 you know
couple minutes before you can see this
this trade I entered in about 15 minutes
before 7 but around this time is when
the larger move bigger banks are
starting to wind up their trade for the
day and so you can see with this trade
is it started a much larger move for the
day and and in this trade I got about 4
and 1 half five times my risk and so in
this trade I was only risking $350 and
so you know that can be a lot for some
people and so for me that's a little
smaller on the size for me right now but
that's how much I entered in for this
trade and we'll definitely talk a little
bit about more why later but I was able
to capture an insanely Big Move going
lower because this is how the market set
up for the day is it had this little
fake hire that timing came into play
which is so important and those factors
that I looked to see show up happened
and then I jumped into a trade based on
that this works just as well in oil
Futures as well you can see here around
7:00 my time again that's 10:00 from
Eastern Market time but I was able to
watch and wait for the market to come
down the oil Market few key factors show
up and then you capture a nice reversal
and I was aftert able to capture a
really nice clean move on the market
here I was up about $2,000 on this trade
and so this is something you can go into
every day and consistently look out for
and repeat that's how you become
consistently profitable trading is
having a plan that you go into and
consistently execute every day you're
going to fail at trading if you go into
trading every day trying to react to
what the market is doing instead wait
for this to happen now there is totally
days where the market doesn't set up you
can see there was kind of of a reversal
at 7:00 but overall pattern of this day
was just kind of ch C and so there
wasn't a really really good reversal and
so you can't just be blindly looking for
okay it's that time I'm going to just
buy or or sell you can you can bet the
Market's going to go down as well like
you saw in that last example but you
have to wait for key patterns to show up
so the biggest factor with finding these
reversals is you have to look for them
at a key Zone either at a support zone
or a resistance Zone and then you time
that up with the
7:00 timing because the whole idea with
that is that you're starting to stack
these things on top of each other
essentially think of this like an
indicator I don't really use indicators
I mainly just use reading candlesticks
but the whole idea is that these are
still indications of what the market
might do and so going into this day what
I was looking at is you know this is
what I do every morning I jump on the
charts around 6:15 and say okay what has
the market done previously because
that's going to show me where it's
likely to reverse in the future and in
this coming day and so you know if you
kind of zoom out a little bit more you
can see okay we've been in a downtrend
and we're kind of in a potential range
right here with an overall downwards
bias so as the market comes up into this
level on this day we can look for that
7:00 timing and bet the market is going
to go lower now what I'm actually
trading here is the es Futures on a
5minute chart I generally look for my
support levels on that 5 minute chart or
the 15minute chart and then I narrow
down into a 1 minute chart when I'm
actually looking to enter into the trade
because that gives you a lot more
accurate of an entry and you can get
really good risk reward based on that
now one thing actually that I've noticed
over time is you can see see the market
has a big move up right here and what
I've noticed is when the market has a
really fast move like this where you can
see just a couple of candlesticks make a
lot of move in price it's a very
unhealthy move and so it's likely to
give that back up and so versus over
here you can see this is a very clean
pullback move where it's a healthy Trend
and so on the way down it kind of moves
in a slow methodical way as well
eventually it does kind of accelerate
down here but the initial move is more
healthy and versus here what it allows
you to do is look for that essentially
very ere exaggerated move and I like to
call this kind of the rubber band effect
is where the market essentially gets too
stretched and so it has to essentially
snap back to kind of an equilibrium
level and a lot of times this can be a
really good profit Target or as a first
profit Target when the market initially
reverses now if it has a lot of momentum
like it did in this scenario it could
keep going lower and so once I find
these key levels is I just look for a
few key factors on these smaller time
frame chart so let me jump now into a
one minute chart and show you the
patterns that I'm looking for and if you
want a 14-page guide of all my favorite
trading patterns and how I kind of focus
and use them you can find that down
below this video it's totally free and
it will be a a lot of detail about these
patterns that I go over if I jump
through them a little too quickly for
you and so right now what we're looking
at is this line right here is where news
is coming out it just disappeared
because that's at that 645 Mark and so
you can see the chart switch there a
little bit because I'm switching back
and forth between looking to trade the
NASDAQ or the es they look very very
similar and so I ended up deciding to
enter in a trade on the es future
and I'm betting here that the market is
going to go down and so a couple of
those key steps that I like to use is
first off is you know we have that
resistance level where we think the
overall big picture is the market could
sell off here and then we have that
timing showing up where we have the
market opened up at 6:30 and then it did
a little bit of that rally up
essentially I would say retested these
pre-market levels and that's pretty key
that it's essentially retesting those
levels and we're seeing a failure of
that I have a little bit of an uptrend
right here drawn and seeing that broken
is another key factor I like to look for
because once that uptrend is broken I
think it's a lot stronger likelihood
that the market is going to move down in
our favor because if you you know have
the market going up nicely in an uptrend
you don't want to be betting against it
right up here when it it hasn't broken
it up Trend at cuz it could just
continue higher and so that's a
confirmation that I really like to love
for two is has that Trend broken
probably the biggest factor in these is
looking at the big picture idea of you
know where this level is what the
overall downtrend is but when it comes
to entering in your trades getting these
last few details is really really
crucial especially when you know you
have a lot of money on the line you know
maybe you're going to start out really
really small and slowly grow which is
what I recommend doing but once you grow
you can see that the money can be really
really big really really fast and you
could be making 600,000 a couple
thousand dollar in minutes and so these
decisions can happen very quickly now
this is sped up just so it you know
doesn't take 40 minutes to play out
because this trade was pretty long I
think if I remember and so this will
allow you though to go in every trading
day have this plan and and then execute
and enter in a trade base on that and so
the last couple things that are really
really important is now this trade was a
little bit more aggressive than normal
so let me go back to that exact entry
just to kind of show you is what I
looked for is the market had a really
fast breakdown like this a big
Candlestick after that news to slow this
down so you can see it pretty easily is
we had a really big rejection bar and I
love that first off that is a massive
signal that you'll see in actually my
threee chart guide that I go over is
that this is a really big crucial
pattern so definitely go and check that
guide out but after seeing that pattern
is look at this other Candlestick right
here and so sometimes I'll see you know
you can have a big bearish candle like
this and then the market will
immediately just reverse it and so the
market actually doing that is it's kind
of doing a bait and switch where it goes
down reverses over these two candles is
it's essentially showing you a reversal
and so instead what happens if I zoom
back here quickly is the market did that
this this candle right here is the
market opened here went up tried to
reverse this candle and then you can see
here it's rejecting and so I put in a
sell order right below the low of this
candle expecting that okay if it gives
that back this little pullback here back
up I'm happy to get in on a push lower
here and so I went to little smaller
size here just because the markets over
this past month was just honestly not
great it was really really choppy and so
I went in almost a third of my size
about 300 I think it was $350 of risk
here I usually try and Target $800 of
risk and so it was a smaller trade and
and it sucks knowing that it worked out
great it would have been a lot bigger of
a win but that's a part of trading you
know I won't get into that I can say
that for another video in terms of
sizing and everything but zooming back
forwards again once it kind of got got
going I moved to break even because it's
really good to take some of that risk
off the table and then from there it was
just managing and seeing what the market
is doing and so I moved my stop loss
down essentially with the swings anytime
I saw you know a pull back here a pull
back here it kind of broke my downtrend
but I had my stop loss here and I
expected okay maybe it makes a little
pull back here and keeps going lower and
you can see here we get down to a
support level and the market just keeps
kind of pushing lower and I'm just
moving down with the lows and so when
the Market's trending really well I
found that it's just best to move down
with the swings it doesn't have to be
insanely complicated you don't need to
do anything fancy in terms of you know
some kind of tight trailing stop loss or
anything I find that it's better to just
move down with the swings and so the
market then just breaks my stop loss
there I got a really nice 4 5x profit on
that trade now that last trade was a
little bit more aggressive in terms of
an entry and I want to show you the more
solid entries that I think you should go
for more right away because that last
entry can definitely get you into
trouble reversing on just a strong
Candlestick like that without this next
signal that I kind of skipped over in
the last one is really really important
and so this trade right here is off of
the NASDAQ 5 minute chart and so what
you can do is you don't have to trade on
a one minute chart if that's that's too
fast you want to focus kind of on a
bigger picture you can this is a trade
showing you that you can enter in based
on a 5-minute chart and it can still
work out in a really big way and so just
to show you you know first thing as
always is here is that kind of support
Zone this was from a 15-minute chart
just looking at the key areas where the
Market's bouncing and then kind of
seeing the market come into that level
seeing this timing pop up I won't go
over this a ton in this video but if you
want to have five key steps to figuring
out how to draw these levels I'll link
them in a video up here and so the key
thing with this strategy and you want to
look out for is well a super basic one
is just look for a double bottom going
back to our charts in the beginning
looking at a ton of these reversals is
look at right here double bottom
Market's made a clean double Bottom
clean double Bottom clean double Bottom
clean double bottom you get the point is
a lot of these and I would say the
better signals are when it makes a
double bottom you know this trade right
here this reverse is at seven but
getting in on a really fast move down
like this I think is really really hard
I think it you know you're trying to
catch a falling knife as the saying is
you can't really do it and so it's
really hard to profitably do that but
you can profitably very consistently
wait for the timing and wait for you
know these double bottoms to show up
where you know it makes a double bottom
and then as well is in this second
bottom right here you can see just look
at the candlesticks and again my 14-page
guide will have a lot more on this is
just reading into these candlesticks
right here kind of these three is the
market comes down and then in that
middle dogee right there it's just
showing it kind of sitting there it's
losing that momentum and it has a big
massive move up and so I like to get in
right there on the break of this candle
because right here here is confirming
you okay this is essentially a mini
reversal and then if you couple that
with this kind of larger reversal it's
essentially a domino effect and so it's
going to help trigger all of the signals
that are potentially going to cause a
larger reversal you know you're going to
have essentially this little mini
reversal right here will help push the
market up a little bit and then this
double bottom will help push the market
up even more and then you know if
there's another bigger signal like in
terms of a fast selloff that'll help
push the market up even more and so that
is something that can be really really
helpful with these trades and so that's
kind of one of the first big things here
with this trade is it has a really clean
double bottom and I would even say that
this is more of a head and shoulders
pattern and it helps push the market up
even more and then again looking at this
kind of Candlestick pattern here of what
I like to call is the retest it's really
strong and so the whole idea with that
kind of stronger signal and why this
works out is if you look at this move
down right here the market has come in
and it's it's bottomed right here it's
kind of made a little move up and then
it's made a massive couple bars move
down so that's a big flush and move and
what that does is well that gets a lot
of people excited and it gets a lot of
momentum moving in the market
potentially compl lower and in this case
you can see it essentially just barely
broke the lows here and then started to
reverse and so what happens there is
that can start to get Traders caught and
trapped on the wrong side of the trade
because instead the Market's starting to
I call it a failed breakout as it's
failed to essentially break out and
again we're in this larger support level
and so what happens is the market moves
up here and I'm not looking to jump in
you know this is more of an aggressive
entry kind of like that last trade we
talked about is if you jumped in right
here I think the safer way is to wait
for essentially it to make a pullback
like this because you know in your basic
Trends you have higher highs and lower
lows and higher highs and higher lows
and so you know these are all lower high
lower high lower high it's essentially a
stair setep pattern down and at some
point right here is that has to change
and so the idea is right here here is
that spot right here and you're going to
essentially then be buying right at the
switch of momentum this essentially
inflection point in the market and it's
going to push higher from there and so
that's what I Look to do is this trade
right here is the market again reading
into the candlesticks is the market just
over these three candles six is the
market moved down it actually made an
attempt to keep going higher that got
reversed and then it actually reversed
that again and so it made basically a
Mini double bottom here and so again
just cascading and Domino those smaller
patterns into the larger patterns and
the larger support level is I jumped in
there and then I put my stop loss below
this low right here and so that's a big
thing is I found that it's best for risk
reward is to put my stop loss below that
low I'm getting in cuz I think that
again going with that market structure I
think it's either going to go like this
or it's going to you know continue
moving lower and I was wrong and that's
okay you have to just accept that losses
are going to be part of trading
sometimes you get in and the pattern it
looks amazing and the market is just
going to do something else and so from
there you know again I looked for just
the market to move up from there and I
was pretty patient with moving my stop
loss once it kind of gave back this
initial move like we kind of talked
about earlier it had a big unhealthy
move lower and so my thought was okay
first Target is right here you know big
picture again we're looking at a 5
minute chart I think big picture if it
breaks out here it's going to go up here
somewhere you know this was more the
overnight high and so that's what I'm
looking for is the market to find some
support level here and get moving with
the trend going higher and so I'm again
just moving to break even and then
moving up with the swings I don't really
have a profit Target because looking for
these larger swings I don't want to cap
my profits I want to the best way to
trade I think is having a fixed risk
amount where you know I'm going to lose
$100 every trade every win has the
potential to be you know a 5x a 10x now
I'm not saying I get those very often on
average I get about three but it allows
you to have larger moves like this when
the market just all of a sudden gets
going in your favor and you don't need
many of these to make your month or your
year especially when you start to get to
larger size at this this trade right
here I think I was risking about $600
and so I'm at about five times my risk
and you can see once the market starts
going it gets a lot bigger and so again
I just kind of moved up with the trend
once it kind of started going a lot
faster in my favor I actually moved down
to a one minute chart and moved up
essentially with these little pullbacks
and so I essentially got out here for a
really nice profit and again this trade
went on a little bit longer than normal
but most of the time I am trading 60 to
90 minutes a day 4 days a week I really
sucked at trading when I first started
out but over time I discovered things
about supply and demand that are the
foundation of what makes me a successful
Trader today and I want to pass on you
the five Concepts that really make or
break a supply and demand level I'll
also show you my strategy that made me
over $9,000 in one month trading 90
minutes a day 4 days a week and if you
can use these five Concepts every time
you draw supply and demand levels you're
going to find levels that hold a lot
more often which will in turn make you a
more profitable Trader let me explain to
you these Concepts from the ground up so
you can go from a Wann toe Trader to
knowing exactly what you need to do
every single day to make consistent
money the whole idea of supply and
demand is you were looking where
previous buying and selling has happened
that shows a clear indication that the
larger Banks or hedge funds are buying
at those levels and what you can do with
this is looking forwards into the future
when a chart gets there you can assume
that it's more likely to bounce off of
one of those Supply or demand levels
like anything in trading it's not going
to work every time but what you can do
is use it to increase your odds of
success now let's go down the list of
the five things I look for every time I
draw a supply and demand Zone if you
don't follow these you are more likely
to draw worse zones which is more likely
to make you lose when you trade off of
them the first one of those is looking
for two clear swings in the chart you're
looking at to draw your supply or demand
level what this does is really give you
a confirmation that the market is likely
to bounce off of that area again I found
over time it's not profitable to draw
off of one bounce cuz it's not confirmed
that the market actually likes that
level it's more like to break through
that level because it's just not as
strong now the one that makes most
Traders fail is drawing too many levels
you do not want to have your chart have
lines all over the place what you want
to do is take those away and not focus
on them because they're more likely to
get you into areas where you think the
Market's going to bounce and then the
market just blows right through that
area because you're not sticking to an
extreme level in the market this area
right here is just in the middle of this
overall range that the Market's
currently in and so it's less likely to
bounce a lot of Traders want to do this
because they think it'll give them more
trades and when you start out you want
to take a lot more trades because you're
excited and you think that's what makes
you successful but what has made me more
successful over time is sticking to the
more extremes in the market which makes
me take less trades but they're more
successful and then through scaling over
time you can can make more profits and
now just looking at these you can see
the market doesn't bounce off these
levels that often and so what I realized
over time is that you want to draw your
supply and demands levels like a Zone
the Market's not going to perfectly
touch a line that you draw in the chart
every time and bounce off of that what
you need to do is instead think of these
like a Zone it's a supply and demand
Zone down here we have a really good
demand Zone where the market is coming
down here a couple times and then we
could assume okay when it comes back
down to this area in the chart it's
likely to find buyers again and what
happens why this happens a lot of the
time if we just zoom in on this is that
because everyone else is looking at the
same thing they see that okay the
Market's bounced here before and either
the big Banks or whatever is coming in
and buying here it's coming in and
saying okay I really like this price
down here but you know what I like this
price here too and up here and so it's
the area they are willing to buy and
when the price comes down here again
well if the stronger that the market is
the more likely it's going to just dip a
little bit and then take off and reverse
from there and so that's why sometimes
you can see that it will reverse really
early in the zone right above the zone
or below the Zone like if we go back to
these swings right here there's two
clear swings right here and you can draw
a Zone here and you can see that the
market broke out of the Zone a little
bit but still failed inevitably and the
same thing if you just extend that over
here well it's still a Zone and so every
time it came up into this Zone the
market still reversed off of that Supply
Zone every time the market got up here
people were wanting to sell it and you
know it's okay that the market broke out
of it a little bit because sometimes the
demand is a little bit more than before
and it just takes a little bit more
selling pressure or time for the supply
to overtake that demand you know it's
all about that economics of that kind of
balance between supply and demand
sometimes there's a balance and after a
while then it sells off from there now
one thing that I've realized that really
can make or break a supply and demand
level is looking at the velocity of the
market when it sold off from that level
when you're identifying it so if we're
trying to identify this Zone up here
this is a great example of the velocity
of the market when it sold off from here
you can see looking at these look at the
candlesticks of the selloff from this
area up here there's three massive
candlesticks selling off from this level
up here and it continued to sell off
from there but that's what we want to
look for is what is the initial selloff
like because that shows you when the
supply for this Supply level up here
really came into play and you can see it
happened again right here the market
sold off very quickly with almost no
pullbacks it's not like it sold off kind
of like this where it was more
consistent methodical downtrend it just
ripped lower and so that for me
increases the probability as we watch
the market come up here for the third
time that yes I can be confident in this
level and that I can look for key
aspects in the market to signal to get
in and then it's going to reverse from
this Zone that's something we'll get to
into a minute but you can see that's
what really helps create these levels is
the velocity off of those zones to show
you example where there's not much
velocity is you can see the market
bounced here multiple times and
eventually you know moved up from here
and So based on that it's a pretty good
Zone you can see the market bounced here
multiple times but if we go forwards in
the chart or I just zoom out so we can
see what happened when the market came
down to this zone is the market just
blew right through that it did kind of
come here and bounce a little bit
initially but eventually it just blew
right through that and so you know that
makes it so it's less like to hold now
of course it could have totally bounced
here and that's why you want to take
these with a grain of salt sometimes is
it's not a stead and fast rule but what
I found is looking for you know that
velocity in the selloff I think makes it
more likely to create a level that you
can trade off of and so this only has
one swing and so sometimes your zones
can actually be really large and so what
I mean by that is look here is there's
no swing up here for a a while and we
don't see anything here yet the market
kind of came up here made basically a
head and shoulders pattern had a big
reversal and then came up to this head
and shoulders pattern area again and it
sold off it you know took a little while
to lose that momentum but it eventually
sold off and so at this point I would
say yeah I think there's some kind of
Zone up here it's really large and so
I'm going to be careful and wait for a
really clear setup because when a zone
is that large you want to be careful and
patient in what the Market's doing and
so the market comes up here again and so
you can see right here it gets close to
the really the highs of our previous
Head Shoulders pattern and so how do you
now decide okay well I want to get in
and bet short here how do you end up
getting in at these levels once you can
identify them and so the last big key
with your zones and levels is draw them
on a larger time frame chart and so
that's what we're looking at here we're
looking at a larger time frame chart
than when I trade this is a 15minute
chart normally I trade on a 1 and a 5
minute chart and you can do this kind of
on any time frame you could do a a 30
minute chart you know the this these
levels pretty much look the same on a 30
minute chart it just kind of drowns out
some of the the noise and back and forth
but you can clearly see swings and draw
zones off of those swings and so that's
what you want to do and then what I do
from there is I essentially zoom in on
this point on a one minute chart and so
if we flip over to a one minute chart to
give you more details this is a one
minute chart of the oil Futures and
we're on the ninja Trader platform and
so you can see now we're budding into
that zone that we have drawn from a
larger time frame chart and so I'm
expecting that okay the Market's going
to slow down here and I want to look for
a reversal opportunity and so you can
see the Market's been really choppy here
and so how do you decide when to take a
stab at this the first thing I want to
wait for when there isn't a lot of
movement like this is I want to start to
see the market actually starting to move
and so the market started to get some
movement here it kind of broke that
previous low now there is kind of maybe
you could draw a minor demand level down
here where it might bounce off of but
once the market comes up to here again
I'm going to be looking for a potential
reversal now it could be scary jumping
into a reversal against the trend and so
that's the trickiest part about reversal
strategy is knowing when to get in one
Candlestick gives you a massive amount
of information of what's Happening
underneath the hood of the market if you
can learn to read them then you can also
start to piece them together and create
domino effect trades that has allowed me
to capture a trade just like this one
this morning where I risked about $600
in that trade and closed up for about
$2600 in profit because if we look at
this Candlestick right here what it's
telling you is it opened up here sold
off and then reversed and closed at the
highs what that tells you is there is
strong momentum over that Cel stick and
it's telling you this story of what is
going on and so what you can do then is
you can use that as well when reading
Candlestick cheat sheets you're going to
be able to throw those out the window
after this because all you need to do is
really read what the candlesticks are
telling you to understand what they mean
and with this Candlestick pattern right
here it's called the three line strike
pattern what the these three bullish
candlesticks say is well the price is
consistently going higher and so what
that does is that creates well on a
smaller time frame upwards trend line
and so what then happens is it breaks
that and then all of a sudden has a
massive selloff and generally when
you're reading charts when a trend line
is broken it's totally possible it
reverses when it breaks it can have a
really big move like this and because it
has a big move like this well it shows
that the momentum is most likely going
to continue lower because there is a
clean methodical move up and all of a
sudden over one Candlestick it's made a
massive move lower and so you can do
this on any Candlestick pattern really
reading into what these are telling you
is generally every pattern is telling
you something but if you read into the
candlesticks it'll tell you even more of
why that Candlestick pattern means that
and I think the strongest one out of
this whole cheat sheet is this inverted
Hammer Candlestick pattern and I'll show
you an actual trade I took that
basically used this but what this
pattern is telling you is you know the
market moved down based on these two red
candlesticks and then it hit here and it
attempted to keep going higher it
started to bounce final momentum and
then it made an attempt to push lower
and I have always found with trading
that when something makes an attempt to
push lower like this and it ends up
failing which is what these two
candlesticks show you is it made that
attempt to go higher It reversed and
then it started to go back higher is
it's showing you a ton and a ton of
strength because well it failed to go
lower and so it makes it more likely to
then reverse and go higher off of that
it essentially makes a little double
bottom here which is a really really
powerful pattern and to quickly show you
another great example of that here's a
trade I had a couple of weeks ago where
right here is where I jumped in and if
you look at these candlesticks you kind
of have that exact same pattern show up
if you look at this right here it's that
exact same pattern and this is
essentially telling you that is the
market was in the downtrend it started
to bounce made an attempt to keep going
lower and then that actually failed and
then it had a big bullish Candlestick
which kind of confirmed that it was
failing of that attempt to go lower and
so for there that was kind of my final
confirmation and we'll go into kind of
the more domino effect in a minute of
getting into this trade and so I jumped
in right here here Market played out
really well in my favor that's where the
domino effect comes into play is this
pattern will show you know a potential
good reversal for a little bit but then
you have to think about the bigger
picture domino effect as well and that
pattern I saw right there was the sole
reason of confirming of me getting into
that trade so going back to the trade
this morning it used the three-line
strike pattern perfectly across all time
frames and it created that domino effect
allowing me to capture a massive move in
the market and so this right here is on
a 1 minute chart but if I go back to my
actual charts and show you and look at
here's a 15-minute chart now we're
looking at the NASDAQ futures of you can
see that three line strike pattern show
up here now my candlesticks are
different colors and I just do that
because I it helps me not be distracted
by the colors but what we have here is
the Market's moving up in a clean
bullish methodical movement and then all
of a sudden there's a massive move down
and of course what that does is there is
a upwards channnel just kind of going
higher on a smaller time frame and so
this is on a 15-minute chart and if we
go to a 5- minute chart of the exact
same time just to confirm that where you
can see that exact same thing just on a
smaller time frame and so this is where
the domino effect you'll start to see
where we have that clean methodical move
higher followed by a big bullish
Candlestick and of course what do those
potentially do they give you that
momentum switch switch lower and then of
course going to an even smaller time
frame you have that as well where this
is basically was my signal for getting
in is you have your couple bullish
candlesticks here I'll just zoom in here
to make it a little clear just I have my
bullish candlesticks here it's kind of
starts to sit there for a minute showing
that loss of momentum you can start to
see it coming in and then boom a big
bearish Candlestick so this is where
that kind of domino effect comes into
play where you're seeing on every
time frame you have that and what does
that do it gives it the potential to
break lower in a massive massive way and
so how this is really effective is the
idea is that the smaller time frame will
trigger first because it's a smaller
pattern and takes less time to play out
because if you look here you know the
price up here is1
18400 and down here it's
18375 and if we go to a 5-minute chart
you can see that 18400 is all the way up
here and by the time this Candlestick is
finished forming that really bearish
move it's already down here at
18352 and then if we go to a larger time
frame if we look at you know maybe this
Candlestick is kind of a better version
of it it's all the way down here right
and so that's where having all of these
align up allows you to jump in based off
of this pattern right here which is the
exact same three line strike pattern and
then you're able to capture the larger
move on a bigger time frame chart this
is what allowed me to if we look at the
trade again is enter in at basically the
highs of the market based on that
smaller one minute pattern but then
capture the bigger swing of the 5 minute
or 15minute pattern as well and so you
can see right there that's where I
basically closed out I closed out at the
support because well the market just
looking at you know the chart here is
well there is kind of a lot of support
here and so I realized that it's better
to get out at that support level but
we'll go into kind of the trade in a
minute and managing it but that's the
whole key is what you can do with
reading into candlesticks is you're able
to Domino the 1 minute into the 5 minute
and the 5 minute into 15 minutes and the
crazy thing is if we look at the other
trade I was talking about from a couple
weeks ago is it's doing this exact same
thing but in reverse and so right here
we have that three-line strike pattern
and if you look at though this blue box
down here is a support Zone and so I'm
expecting the market to bounce off here
if we just zoom out you can see the
markets come down here multiple times
and bounced off this area and so I'm
assuming that well when it comes down
here again it's going to do that and so
you know there's a little sneak peek
oops of what actually happens but as
we're looking at this in real time you
can see that this can also be a reversal
strategy if it's used in the proper
place because it's essentially giving
that methodical move higher which is
showing some strength off of the lows
and then all of a sudden there is that
massive move down and what happens when
moves to the downside fail well it gives
the market more likelihood to reverse
and so if we go into a smaller time
frame of looking at that on a 5-minute
chart now this is again we're still
looking at the NASDAQ futures is the
market bounced here when in kind of a
methodical move up and then boom showed
a big amount of weakness to the downside
which can show an attempt to keep
pushing pushing lower but if you use
that with the understanding that the
market starts to then bounce and
continue to go sideways and show
actually it making a higher low right
here and really a head and shoulders
pattern well that is starting to show a
reversal because what this pattern can
do is it can make people think that it's
going to go down because again using
this pattern is a lot of the time it
does show strong momentum to the
downside but in in this case it's
overextended and it's moved too far and
it's going right into a big support Zone
and so if we then go further into a one
minute chart you can see that again same
thing is it's that methodical move up
big move down and then when we see it
start to bounce here we can look for an
entry into the trade and so again
remember that pattern we just saw right
here I then use that as well to confirm
that it was likely to move up and if we
zoom in on a one minute chart remember
this this is the pattern we were looking
at on a 5 minute and this is what it
looks like if you dive deeper into the
candlesticks and so this is where that
double bottom basically happened and as
it essentially broke here that was my
confirmation for getting in and so with
this trade I basically coupled two
different patterns I coupled it with
this in terms of it showing a failure to
go lower and then I combined it with
this pattern on a one minute chart of
when it made that extreme low and then
started to make a higher low here
confirming that head and shoulders
pattern we had and from there it Domino
effects to where this smaller pattern
right here shows the reversal to this
and then going up to a 5 minute this
pattern right here gives the potential
for it to move even higher and then if
we go out to a 15-minute chart where we
just look at the big picture well if the
market reverses this larger Trend down
well we have a likelihood to continue to
reverse and make a larger Trend higher
and a perfect Target for this is if you
look at this move down here a lot of the
time when the market makes a clean move
like this to the downside if it's going
to reverse that that's a really good
Target and you can see once the market
kind of had this consolidation and then
broke out of that it made a very clean
fast move to this high and then it
started to just chop around from there
because that's where there is a gap
between the support and resistance
levels and so this is why I use larger
levels as my support and resistance
zones because it allows you to use that
domino effect and then you go down to a
smaller time frame chart enter in on the
trade based on more of a micro pattern
which gives you a more accurate entry
right at the lows and then once it gets
going I usually manage it based on what
I'm seeing and this was I then Managed
IT on a 5-minute chart because the
market was moving pretty clean and I was
able to capture about
$2900 on that trade now let's go back
back to the trade I entered in this
morning and let me walk you through the
fstep checklist that I Ed to jump into
these trades this Candlestick walk
through and detail about how I read them
is really only one portion of how I
enter into these trades and then how I
then manage them and with this trade
this morning I actually did something
I've never done on a trade before and it
allowed me to basically not get knocked
out at break even and capture this whole
swing and so it was really lucky that I
did that and so let me take you back to
this morning before this happened and
why and how I got into this trade now
we've already talked about the
Candlestick pattern and the whole three
line strike pattern of what we're
looking for but when I first open my
charts this morning this is what the
market looked like is we're looking at
the NASDAQ futures and the market had
big moves like this and so where are the
key areas of support and resistance that
is my first thing I always want to look
for because I'm looking for reversal
trades you want to be trading off of of
the key levels and so here well the
Market's bounced off of the highs and
lows here multiple times and so that's
why I drew a support Zone and a
resistance Zone and then I always do
that on a 15-minute chart the whole idea
is again thinking about that domino
effect I want to see the big picture
levels because that's where it's more
likely we're going to have a larger move
lower off of those levels and so looking
at this this morning if we go to a
5-minute chart I like to go into these
smaller time frames again because using
in that domino effect I want to get a
more accurate entry and so the Market
opens up at 6:30 my time I'm on the west
coast and so the market opened right up
here and so the first couple minutes if
we actually go into a minute chart just
because it'll show you a little bit more
action is the first couple minutes of
the market are usually pretty pretty
crazy and so I always stay out of the
market for the first 10 to 15 minutes
just because the market always has noise
when it first starts out and so it could
go like this and like this and so I
don't want to jump in a trade and get
knocked out in this garbage right here
and so what I was looking for this
morning and what I actually posted in
the chat room as well I wanted to see
the market either make a double top here
or some kind of breakout of the previous
High because I wanted to see it make an
attempt to break this high and then fail
because I always again kind of going
with that reversal Green Line strike
pattern is I want to see the market make
an attempt to go the opposite direction
and fail because I always find that as
the strongest way to jump in and capture
reversal in the other direction and
another thing the second actually thing
in my checklist is always making sure
that the current uptrend is broken and
so you can see on a one minute chart
here I've gone off the lows and the
market kind of bounced here I wanted to
make sure that the uptrend is broken you
know maybe you could draw here that
one's broken and so any uptrend line
that I try and draw is broken and the
key there is that once that's broken
just like with this three line strike
pattern is you know it generally has an
uptrend and then once that uptrend is
broken well it opens the door for the
market to make a clean reversal and so
that's exactly what I'm looking for
every time I look for a reversal I want
to see that uptrend broken and then from
there I want to see the market make an
attempt that attempt to keep going
higher I never jump in on the break of
that trend line because the market a lot
of the time like you see here is it
moving lower and then broke and reversed
higher and so as this is printing
candlesticks I'm now thinking okay now
I'm on a 1 minute chart I am looking for
that final confirmation I want to see it
essentially fail here and make our three
line strike pattern form and I will jump
in on the low or the break of that
Candlestick if we actually switch over
to the recording now because that'll
show you more of what I'm doing in real
time is the market moved up here and so
I'm just thinking okay either this is
going to break out higher or it's going
to reverse and show a nice bearish
Candlestick and I want to jump in on
that and so all of this is about
patiently waiting for that setup to
happen and so as it starts to break this
and so this red bearish Candlestick
right here again is not enough you need
a big Candlestick like this and so it's
hard waiting through that Candlestick
because it can be it can feel like oh my
God I'm going to miss out and instead I
always wait for the candlestick the
close and then from there the market
just chopped around for a little while
and so my thought was okay that's okay I
want to get in on a break of the low of
this Candlestick and so it then breaks
that and then from there it shoots lower
and so I put my stop loss above here as
my thought is you know what if the mark
comes down here and breaks and keeps
going higher again we're going based off
of the structure of the market and so
because of that I want to get out and
cut my losses at that point the whole
idea is because because I'm taking
reversal trades I risk a smaller amount
to gain a larger amount and so and so in
N Trader if we go back to the actual
chart I have a risk reward tool that
tells me exactly how many contracts I
need to trade to hit a fixed risk amount
this is something I've actually created
and what it does is it just allows me to
say okay if I'm going to get in here and
I'm going to put my stop here I want to
try and Target about $600 of risk per
trade and so it'll then essentially if
you you look at this it'll then adjust
of okay well now you need 200 two
contracts to Target that 600 risk and so
it allows me to stay at a safe amount
and then down here you can see the
targets also show how much I'll make if
the market gets there and so I like to
always Target 3x at a minimum I like to
make sure that the swing potential if
the market does go to the other end of
the range is at least 3x now of course
it can keep going or sometimes I get
less based on just managing the trade
but that is something I always use every
trade because I find it so important and
so the market started going in my favor
and it made a little pull back here and
kept going lower and so I'm thinking big
picture that the market is either going
to sell off here and keep going lower or
it's going to reverse and knock me out
and I'm okay getting out and so the one
thing I did here that I've actually
never done before is as I saw the market
come up here you see how my stop loss is
right here above this High I actually
moved it back to break even and the
reason why did this is because I
realized that the Mark was kind of being
choppy but I made a conscious decision
that I'm okay going back to break even
because I think the market needs as much
wiggle room as I can give it and I'm
okay giving it up until break even and
so you can see right here is the market
my stop was originally right here the
market would have knocked me out right
there and instead it barely moved up
there and then reverse back lower and so
it kind of chopped around here for a
little while and so I'm just still here
just sitting you know waiting for this
to play out because the big thing that
I'm looking at is if we go to a larger
time frame is you know the Market's
about here is that there is no support
anywhere in this area and so for me I
see that as there is nothing holding
this up if it breaks lower here all it
is is there's just anytime you're
trading a reversal is you the Market's
going to go up lose momentum and then it
might just sit there and chop for a
while before it switches that momentum
low and So eventually if we go back to
this now it's all of a sudden that
momentum is Switched and so it just
takes time to do that and sometimes at
that can take minutes hours and so all
of a sudden you know I don't know what
happened maybe some news came out I you
know the market just cratered and so for
me I'm thinking well the Market's been
choppy and you can see we're at that
support level now I switched to a very
tight trailing stop because we're above
my profit Target now and so what I did
was I moved to just the previous
Candlestick high and so I just as we
move down just previous Candlestick High
here this Candlestick was so big that I
moved to the middle of the range I think
if I had multiple contracts I probably
would have just taken one off here or
moved my stopy here and had the other
one here but I was trading only one
contract because that's what I'm my risk
allowed over the last few years I grew a
small account where I was making a
couple of $100 per trade to now where I
am making a couple of ,000 per trade let
me let me walk you through the five
steps you need to follow to do exactly
what I did and a strategy that you can
use that only takes 90 minutes a day to
execute so you aren't spending hours and
hours at a computer you can go and live
your life the first thing to figure out
is what brokerage to use this can 100%
depend on where you are in the world but
go with the larger brokerages the
smaller ones can often be unregulated or
trying to scam you in some way and
brokerages are so competitive now that
the fees are practically the same across
the board and so going with the bigger
ones is actually safer for you the
brokerage I use is called ninja Trader
but if that isn't available in your area
the other great option that's available
pretty much everywhere is trading view
now when it comes to day trading you
can't day trade normal stocks if you
have under $25,000 in your account and
that's a massive amount if you're trying
to start small there's a rule called the
pattern day trading rule rule that says
you can't have more than three trades in
5 days which is if your day trading
isn't a fun rule to try and deal with
but Futures which is another asset you
can trade doesn't have that rule you can
start with an extremely small account
and take as many trades as you want also
Futures trade almost 24/7 allowing you
to trade any time of the day no matter
where you are if you want a really
detailed walkthrough of how Futures work
I'll link my in-depth tutorial on that
that up here as a basic thing is Futures
allow you to get a ton of Leverage
around 450x if you're trading the S&P
500 this is why you can make really good
returns with a small account of course
there's risk involved but there are ways
to protect yourself you want to First
figure out your risk tolerance how much
are you planning to risk per trade I
always say you should start initially
with a simulated account because you
want to figure out your strategy and
everyone makes mistakes when they
initially start out and mistakes in
trading lose you money but when you are
ready figure out how much you want to
risk per trade I currently risk about
$600 to $700 per trade but when I
started out it was way lower like 50 or
100 per trade now massive blunder that I
made that I think lost me a couple years
of successful trading was having a bad
risk reward ratio you need to figure out
what kind of risk reward ratio you want
to go for so when you're risking like
$50 when you start out how much profit
are you targeting for every trade
there's a lot of information out there
that has a strategy that they say oh
this strategy has a 95% win rate but
when you look at their risk reward ratio
it's because they have a really bad risk
reward ratio where they're risking
something like $50 to make $25 and that
might seem good initially but when they
lose it's a big amount and takes out
multiple wins and I've realized over
time it's way better to have a positive
risk reward ratio anywhere between
between 1 to one or 1 to3 where you're
risking $100 to make $100 or risking
$100 to make $300 this allows you to
make more from your wins than losses and
even though your win rate won't be as
high because to have a risk reward ratio
like that your trade has to go farther
in your favor the math will play out in
the long run and it allows you to make
more from your wins and losses and even
though your win rate won't be as high
the impact of your losses won't easily
blow of your account and when you're
starting out that is everything success
in trading is about staying alive when
you're first starting out and staying
alive is not losing money and blowing up
your account when you're starting out
I'd suggest go for something super
simple like 1:1 or 1 to2 risk reward
ratio where you're risking $100 and
you're just going for $200 a win now
when it comes to safely growing your
account risk percentage per trade is
really important I would not risk more
than 5% of your account on any single
trade when you first start out because
this is again is protecting you from
potentially blowing up your account and
getting washed out of trading or having
to put more money that you don't want to
put up into trading I'd say it's best to
not risk more than 5% of your account
per trade even when you start but once
you grow that size reduce it because the
actual money gets to be too big right
now I risk about 2 and 1 12% of my
account account but the dollar amount is
now larger and I don't have the risk
tolerance to deal with risking more
dollar per trade it's a balance between
percentage but also the reality of how
much the money affects you when you're
putting up you know $1,000 per trade
that's an insane amount of money and it
takes time to be okay with that and
especially confidence when you first
start out trading and so even when you
start out $50 might be a lot and so it
takes time to grow that mental strength
to deal with the volatility of trading I
remember when I first started out
betting $100 or $150 and taking that
loss was really really impactful and now
where I'm at that seems like a really
small amount of money but it's about
going through that growth phase and
figuring out where you are in it
everyone is at a different point start
where it makes sense for you and grow
from there now big thing with trading is
growth there's a lot of poor ways to do
this and a lot of bad information making
you think that it might be really easy
to grow a small account to hundreds of
thousands in just one year when it comes
to trading you have to think of it as
percentage the S&P 500 on average does 7
to 9% a year and that's really good
gains and so if you can trade and make
something like 20% per year that can be
really insanely good too think about if
you're trading a million dooll account
and you you make 20% return that year
that's
$200,000 but if you then reduce that to
$1,000 and you make 20% return which is
still really good you're only making
$200 that year which seems like nothing
and a complete waste of time and so
that's where trading is hard initially
because you want to make that return but
the real power of trading is that
exponential growth and that ability to
make massive amounts of money when you
get to that point of having a really big
account now I started an account with
$5,000 a couple years ago and I grew it
100% in that year which is an insane
return but it's still only $5,000 that
year and so that's where you have to
disconnect from trying to make a lot of
money right away and instead focus on
learning and mastering the strategy
because it would still take you years of
100% gain per year to start making a
large income that could potentially
replace your full-time job and it's
unlikely those gains happen consistently
and even making that 20% is still a
massive impactful percentage when it
comes to the reality of gains you can
have trading and so the way to get
around this is go into trading and
building your small account with the
plan of you are practicing and mastering
your skills it's not about the money
right now and over time your account
will grow and when you are ready you can
add on to your account once your risk
tolerance increases and you have shown
consistent profits because if you start
with as little as $500 even 100% growth
every year which is amazing is going to
take you a decade to get anywhere
reasonable and now those percentages
can't be just done over one trade the
idea is this is done over a ton of
Trades showing consistency anyone can
get lucky with one trade it's about
showing consistency over the long run
with a good amount of trade I wouldn't
consider adding on to your account until
you're consistently over a whole trading
year with real money then the second
goal of this is to start to scale up
your account so you can actually start
making that impactful income you are
looking for trading you can even add
more money to your account to increase
your trading and risk size per trade and
grow your account faster if you think
the risk is worth it and you're
confident in your abilities but again I
wouldn't do this until being
consistently profitable with real money
on a smaller account because trading
takes a long time to really prove that
you're consistently profitable you can
be profitable for your first month but
you could have just got lucky you need
to prove that you can be profitable when
the market is good and bad for your
strategy it's easy to make money when
the market has good movement but when
all of a sudden it switches and you
aren't experienced with dealing with
that it can catch you off guard and you
can blow your account up really easily
now none of this matters if you do not
have a strategy that you can
consistently work on mastering every
single day let me now walk you through
the strategy that I have used for the
last 3 years to grow a small account
into a larger one we're going to go over
three different size trades throughout
that process so I can show you the
different steps you want to be taking at
each phase of the process so over the
years I struggled a ton with trying to
find different strategies that work and
I eventually realized that making it as
simple as possible and trading only one
strategy and pattern was way more
successful for me and so what I do is
all I look for is key areas of
resistance and support and I trade
reversals off of them so anytime the
market comes up to a resistance level I
look for a couple key patterns and I bet
the Market's going to go down and I make
money as the market either goes down and
then when it comes down to a support
level I close out of the trade or or if
I am not in a trade I look for the
pattern to show up and then I make money
as the market goes up and so for me I
found this works way better and I'm able
to take a small amount of risk and then
profit a larger amount having that
really good risk reward ratio and so
this trade right here this is with a
tiny tiny account my risk on this trade
right here is I think about $40 at the
time and so this is my stop- loss up
here if the market comes up here and
hits that I will close out of the trade
at a loss and so this is a big thing
when you're trading is you always want
to have a stop loss in place and you
don't want to ever move it farther away
and increase your potential risk on the
trade because that is a really really
good way to accidentally blow up your
account and lose more money than you
meant losses in trading happen you just
have to accept them and move on to the
next trade and so that's all I do every
day I go into the market and I look for
reversal trades and it keeps it super
simple sometimes a reversal trade
doesn't show up but that's totally okay
and again I'm trading the mees Futures
here if you want to learn more about
Futures check out that video that I
linked I traded this size for quite a
while and slowly grew my account you can
see here I'm up about $90 on this trade
and I was risking about $40 and so
that's about 2 and 1 half times my risk
and from there I was able to close it
out at about if I just zoom forwards
because this is a recording from a trade
years ago I closed it out at about $85
it looked like there and so that was a
really nice gain especially if you're on
like let's say a $500 or $1,000 account
that's a really really good start to
your growth and so to jump forward in my
trading I was growing that account and
now in this trade right here I am
risking about
$150 and I'm going for that fixed risk
reward and so I'm going for two X and so
if the market comes up to about here I
will make about $300 and so that's
important when you first start out is go
for a fixed risk reward ratio it'll make
it simpler on you because there's
already so many things to figure out and
focus on in trading and so if you look
at this trade right here the main things
if we start to look at why I'm getting
into these trades is I am just looking
and reading the price action or the
candlesticks of what's going on and so
I'm looking at the market is clearly in
a downtrend right here and it has some
kind of big movement here and then a big
flush lower here and you can see it
comes down to this support level that
I've previously drawn and so again we're
looking at a one minute chart here
that's what I like to trade you can
trade this on really any market and time
frame you want because again all you're
looking at is reading the candlesticks
of what they're telling you but for this
support level down here I actually draw
on a 15-minute chart the whole idea of
looking at a larger time frame is if
looking at a 15-minute chart here is
looking at the key areas all I like to
look for in my support zones like this
or resistance zones is I like to see the
larger picture of where the Market's
bouncing and so that's how I draw these
levels is seeing that okay the market is
bouncing let's say here twice and so I
can draw this Zone and see that okay
well if the market comes down here again
I can look for it to bounce there again
potentially now I'm not going to go over
the five key concepts of how I draw
these support and resistance levels in
this video but you can check it out
right here and so with this trade I just
wait for the market to come down to one
of these levels and then I look for a
couple key factors of course I always
like to make sure that the downtrend is
broken and so you can see it had a
really nice methodical downtrend here it
broke that and then what is happening
right here is I like to see is the Mark
has made a very clean flush lower and
what happens in that case is it can
think of it like a rubber band rubber
band stretches and then it can snap back
because there's that elasticity and
force trying to pull it back to
equilibrium and so the market acts like
that a lot and it can do that and so
when it does that down to a support
level like this like I've drawn it's
more likely to do that the key that I
really liked about getting in here is
you can see the market basically made a
double bottom is the market came down
here bounced I don't like buying that
first bounce cuz you don't know what's
going to happen the market could bounce
briefly and then just keep going lower
it's hard to trade reversals and so you
have to have a few key Concepts and so
then I waited for it to bounce again it
had a really nice strong bullish
Candlestick here and then I jumped in
the trade right here and I put my stop
loss down here below the previous level
where this support Zone was drawn off of
and so that's how I used to look for
these key areas and take trades off of
and you can see there boom I closed out
at looks like about $350 on that trade
and that's a really nice win and that's
way larger than that $84 that I made in
that last trade so this is how the
growth happens over time and so now
jumping forwards I'm risking even more
per trade as this process continues and
so how you want to be doing that is when
you're risking let's say $100 well you
can increase it to 150 because that's a
50% increase in size that's really big
and then maybe you can go to 200 if you
felt like that's still a big increase
and then maybe from 200 you can go to
300 and then 300 you can go to 400 450
it's all about finding that balance of
what works for you and then as well what
you can start to do is you can start to
change how you manage your trade and so
initially you know I would go for that
fixed risk reward where I'd risk that
$100 and I'd always go for that $200 of
profit now I have realized over time
that I can start to read the market a
little bit better while I'm in a trade
and this is a skill that develops over
time D learning to do this when you
first start out I would not recommend it
I would stick with keeping that fixed
risk reward and then learning to manage
over time because there's a it's very
emotional when you're in a trade it's
it's a lot of pressure and a lot going
on and you know seeing the candlesticks
like this move and your dollar amount
move up and down is very very stressful
and so when the market goes against you
you know it opens you up for making
mistakes more than you could when you
just leave it at that fixed risk reward
ratio because then you allow just the
math to play out but over time I changed
this I said you know what I think I can
do it now I want to try this because I
think that I can manage this and go for
a more fluid risk reward where it's like
you know sometimes I make 2 x on a trade
sometimes it's three sometimes it's four
or five and so it it opens you up for
having a really a fixed amount where on
this specific trade right here I am
risking I think about $600 per trade and
this trade makes way more than that it
goes somewhere down here or even further
off the screen making me about 5x that
is a really really big key when it comes
to managing your trades and how you
change your trading over time but again
when it comes to my actual strategy it's
always Remains the Same
I always have a fstep checklist and
process that I go for in every single
trade so let me take you through that
fstep process right now so you have a
little bit more understanding so first
thing is always drawing that either
support or resistance Zone and just wait
for the market to get there and so
looking at here the Mark's come up here
once it's come down here come up here
come down and so I think there's a
pretty clear area of support down here
at the lows and resistance down here at
the highs and so when you you know just
go go to the right you kind of wait for
the market to come up into this
resistance area again and then you dive
into a smaller time frame because again
this is on a 15-minute chart and you
look for these few steps to bet the
Market's going to go lower and capture a
really nice risk reward ratio and get a
good return on that trade and so then
I'll dive into a one minute chart and
wait for the market to come up to that
level and so that's step one is just
being patient and waiting for it to get
to these key levels trust me I've tried
finding more levels looking at you know
a one minute chart like this and being
like Oh the Market's bounced here
bounced here maybe there's a support
level there I'll take a trade I've lost
money doing that more than I've made
stick to the key levels it sucks being
patient but just do it trust me it'll
save you a lot of money and headache
being patient and cherry picking for the
best trades is really how you make money
day trading you don't have to make a ton
of Trades every day to make money it's
more about taking a small small number
of Trades that are consistently
profitable and so step two again is
going back and looking at making sure
that uptrend is broken and so you can
see here I have this trend line drawn I
kind of Drew it matching this low right
here this little pullback it had and
then even this little pullback it had
here and so you know it started to kind
of break that line here but I always
like to go along with the rule of it
needs to be clearly broken and I would
say it was clearly broken after this red
candle stick closed and broke out of
that that the next step in this is
looking for a couple of patterns and so
I like to kind of think of training as
like a domino effect and kind of a big
picture medium picture small picture and
so the big picture is looking at that
15-minute time frame and seeing where
the bigger overall trend is and then
going to a one minute chart and reading
okay what is the smaller trend on the
one minute we need to wait for that to
break and then even smaller is looking
at okay what is a pattern Candlestick
pattern that shows up when it gets to
that level and so in this case what I
see is the market has a lot of big
momentum right here again think about
that rubber band effect we just talked
about these three candlesticks if we
kind of draw what happened there is the
market shot up here and then over the
next two candlesticks it kind of sold
off and so to me that is the market
making an attempt to break higher and it
being rejected if the market was going
to have really a lot of strength here I
think it it could have a little bit of a
pull back here and and then keep going
or even here it would pull back here and
keep going and break out but you can see
here it made a double top and then that
attempt to break out right here actually
stopped lower than this previous high
right here this is slightly lower than
the last one if you look at those candle
wicks and then it started to fail and so
exact same thing is it's that rubber
band effect of it failing if you just
look over here you can see the exact
same thing happened is the the market
had a nice methodical Trend going higher
you know the candlesticks are about the
same size it starts to pick up speed
boom all of a sudden three big
candlesticks over 3 minutes shoots the
price higher and then you can see
there's some it starts to go sideways
and then all of a sudden boom it goes
back lower that's exactly how the rubber
band effect works and so this is just
kind of a smaller version of that and
having that coupled with what we're
seeing here really helps of having it be
at that level the trend breaks after it
makes this double top and then the final
thing I like to look for is that
momentum start to switch and so this
right Candlestick right here this
massive bearish one that is a amazing
indicator of yeah the the momentum is
clearly switching the only problem with
this size of Candlestick is I like to
put my stop loss of where I'll get out
of the trade if it goes against me above
that previous high right here and if you
see here well if you enter here and put
your stop loss all the way up here well
that makes your risk very very big and
so you can still change how much you're
risking you can have a enter here and a
stop loss here be $100 and you can have
this stop loss right here be $100 as
well it just depends on how many shares
or contracts or whatever Market you're
trading you trade you know maybe you
just trade one share here and it takes
three over here but the biggest thing
with that is realizing that well if I
enter here and my stop is here and I'm
risking $100 to make $100 well the
market has to go all the way down here
versus over here well if my risk is
right here well to make $100 it just has
to go right here and to make 200 it has
to go here and so you know if you
compare that to over here you're making
about $300 when this trade over here
makes only $100 and so that's something
to keep in mind don't go after these
that's I would say that's kind of
chasing and so you have to find a middle
ground right here where you can see this
is showing a nice rejection and it show
you exactly where I entered the market
made you know this double top and then
these two bearish candlesticks breaking
that downtrend and so I put a buy order
or technically a sell order right below
that previous low of that candle and so
then the market broke that low I thought
that was just a a nice little micro
pattern a breakout pattern to get in on
I got in I got technically three
contracts and so here I'm I'm shorting
the market I'm betting that the market
goes lower I make money as the market
goes down and so I put my stop- loss up
here had a fixed amount of risk and then
from there the I let the trade play out
and so now I have a more fluid
management sty so here you can see I
moved my stop loss to break even and so
if the market decides to come down here
and go against me I can get out without
losing money I've taken risk off the
table and so you see down here there's a
previous support level that I've drawn
and so that's something to be aware of
of okay we're getting down to the lows
you know even though this isn't a big
support level that I want to take a
trade off of well the Market's moving
down so quick it could bounce here and
you know you know I'm up over three
times my risk you want to get out of
your trade when you start to win and and
make a good amount of money right cuz
again thinking about that R band effect
you don't want to have come down here
and then snap back on you and then all
of a sudden the market moves really fast
some kind of news popped or something
and so at that point you know I start
moving my stop down really quick and
decide to close out you know I have this
little downtrend here but letting it
come back all the way here that's a
massive amount of money I would rather
get out at you know about 5X and you can
see now it's $3,000 per tradeing so
that's a lot of money that starts to
mess with you even when you start to get
used to it I lost over $30,000 before I
turned my trading around and started
making thousands per month trading here
are 15 lessons that would have made me a
profitable Trader 5 years earlier a
trick that has saved so many losses for
me is going break even on your trade
after you have given it time to play out
that whole idea with this is once the
market starts to go in your favor and
I'm right here I'm betting that the
Market's going to go down I want to move
my stop to break even because the whole
idea is that if the market is going to
reverse here it's probably going to go
pretty quickly but if for some reason
it's not going to do that you want to
get out of the trade out of scratch you
want to just move on because the whole
idea with trading is you have an idea
and the Market's either going to follow
that idea potentially or it's just not
going to and if you let the idea have a
chance to start to play out but then if
it's got to an inflection point like
here where okay either it's going to
keep going down or it's going to reverse
and go all the way up reversing and you
know you're wrong on the trend you want
to get out at break even and just move
on to the next trade it's so easy to get
married to an idea of a trade and in
reality what you need to do is just get
in let the idea play out and get out if
it's not going to work you 100% have to
trade with a stop loss and you cannot
move it farther away once you're in a
trade if you do it's a Surefire way to
lose more than you meant and end up
blowing your account this is a terrible
Habit to start that will make you lose
as a Trader losing is a part of trading
accept it and move on to the next one
you don't need to trade every day to
make good consistent money trading take
a day off if you aren't FOC focused
trading can seem like a game but it's
the hardest game you will ever play in
your life only play it when you're at
your Peak practice on a simulated
account then switch to real money start
out with as little as possible because
when real money is on the line emotions
come into play and it completely changes
the game I get emails all the time from
people saying they've lost tens of
thousands of dollars trying to learn
when they could have made those same
mistakes and lost zero money trading a
simulated account having too many
indicators is going to cause analysis
paralysis I personally don't use any
indicators because I find it way easier
to just be profitable just reading the
candlesticks and looking at the chart
patterns but if you do want to use
indicators only use a few your charts do
not have to look crazy effective trading
is simple so many issues from Trading
come from over trading Revenge trading
or fomo which is the fear of missing out
trading can be really stressful and
cause you to make worse decisions the
more time and the more trades you take
in a day I realized it was way easier to
have those not affect me if I only took
one trade a day a lot of my students
have even found it insanely helpful
because it helps them deal with the
emotions of trading and essentially
skirt around them also what this does is
it helps you practice patience and
cherry picking only the best trades
which will make you more profitable when
it comes to trading not every trade is
the same really every trade is different
there's infinite possibilities in the
market even if you're going for the same
strategy or pattern every time there's
always something slightly different
about the market no two trades are the
same so sometimes you may see a trade
and think it's a decent setup but not
good enough for your full trading size
still take a stab at it because it's
worth your time to take that trade
you've CLE clearly spotted that there's
something saying that there's
opportunity there a smaller size trade
may not seem worth your time because
it's less money but trust me the money
adds up over time people always want to
know about what the news is when they're
trading if it's going to be good or if
it's going to be bad because the logical
thing is to think well if the news is
good the Market's likely to go up and if
it was bad the Market's likely to go
down but this isn't how the market works
the market will price in an expectation
going into a new news event let's say we
have a news event about to come out at
this time well the market is going to
have an expectation and if it expects
the news to be good will the price of
whatever you're looking at is going to
increase and then when the news comes
out well it's going to have to fit what
that expectation is and so if the market
already expected the news to be good
well it might not move anywhere the
market just kind of might go sideways
and so you might be confused that well
the the news was good why isn't the
market going up now or on even the worst
side is the market over expects the news
to be really really good and then it
actually isn't as good as you it was
supposed to be and so the market sells
off even after good news came out and so
that's where trading news can really I
think just be the biggest kind of
gambling when it comes to trading
because you cannot know what it's going
to do when it comes out even if you get
it right that the the news is going to
be good you don't know if the Market's
going to go up sideways or down because
you don't know what it's already done
beforehand and its expectation going
into that news event the only profit way
I have found trading into a news event
is not be in a trade get out of a trade
before a news release comes out and then
once the news pops you can then see what
the market does see how it reacts to the
news and then enter in a trade based on
what you're seeing if that fits your
strategy the market will always tell you
what it thinks through the price
movement of the chart you don't have to
spend time guessing what it thinks of
the news release all you have to do is
just look at what the chart is telling
you just read the chart a painstakingly
but extremely important thing to the
success that you're trading is
journaling your trades and your patterns
that you're taking but also Journal your
emotions understanding what patterns you
are being successful with is is the key
to your success at trading what made me
successful was realizing I was the best
at taking one style of trading and
cutting everything out I started to just
focus on trading reversals and that's it
after I started cutting out all the
other opportunities and moves that I saw
in the market that I thought I could
catch I saw my results really turn to
being profitable and I wouldn't have
been able to do that if I wasn't paying
attention attention to what was working
and what wasn't in my trading I saw
drastic results when I made this change
in my trading when I started out trading
I started going for a 2:1 risk reward
ratio and what this means is I was
risking $100 to make 50 and what I
didn't realize is this was setting me up
for failure initially trading like this
it seemed like it would work because
when you jump into a trade the market
doesn't have to move very far for you to
win it will actually increase your win
rate
but when you lose you lose way more than
you are winning over time and the math
doesn't play out in your favor what I
found was better was flipping this and
going for a 1 to2 risk reward Ratio or
one to three risk reward ratio where you
are risking let's say $100 to make $300
the trade does have to go farther in
your favor for you to win and it will
reduce your win rate but when you win
you win way more money than you lose and
so that that's where win rate isn't
everything when it comes to trading also
what this does is it mentally really
helps you with your losses because when
you lose they're not as big of a deal so
they don't cause you to potentially
emotionally spiral and have more issues
trading make sure you're trading the
correct time frames when it comes to
trading swing Traders generally are
looking at Daily or hourly charts
whereas scalpers are generally looking
at smaller time frames when I trade
trade I'm a scalper I look at a 1 minute
a 5 minute a 15 or the most up to a 30
minute chart but a mistake I see many
Traders making is looking at something
that is out of the time frame that they
are trading for example if you're
looking to trade on a one minute chart
looking at what the market is doing on a
daily chart doesn't make sense you know
the market is in an uptrend on the daily
chart right now but if you're looking to
trade on a one minute chart you can see
on a one minute chart there is
downtrends potentially happening at that
time on a one minute chart and so
looking at what the market is doing on a
daily chart when you're looking to trade
on something small like a one minute
chart or even vice versa is a complete
waste of time because the daily chart is
such a larger time frame that the
patterns and Trends take way longer to
play out that even if you see an uptrend
like we have on the daily chart right
now you can still find a downtrend
tradable opportunity on a 1 minute chart
and if you let the uptrend of the daily
chart influence your decision you might
actually skip a good trade on a smaller
time frame you still want to be aware of
the big picture but usually looking at
something like a 15minute chart or a
30-minute chart over the past couple
weeks will give you a good enough
information of what the market is doing
and where those Trends are that you need
to be paying attention to you really
need to be aware of the market structure
and what it it's telling you you really
need to be aware of when the market is
really going sideways and there is
extremely low volatility in the market
because the market is more likely to
give you signals to jump into a trade
potentially and it's easier for you to
fomo into something and in reality on
days like this where the market is just
sitting there doing nothing it's better
to just skip trading for the day versus
if you see a over here where the market
then starts to have movement you can
take trades a massive thing is looking
at okay if I enter for a trade right
here is there movement for me to hit 1X
2x three times my risk and make a
profitable trade if you're looking to
buy down here and there's a resistance
zone right here that doesn't allow you
to get to your two times or three times
your risk which is your target you
should not be taking the trade either
that is another big thing about Market
structure that people Overlook is making
sure your trade has room to profit and
that it's actually worth the risk of
even getting in that location even when
your pattern shows up and tells you to
get in over time your intuition will
give you signals about the market this
is because you have learned to recognize
patterns subconsciously when you're
trading through experience if something
feels off about a trade you're about to
get into Don't Force the trade my best
trades almost always have the feeling of
oh my God this is exactly how I want
this to set up I have to get in right
now now don't get me wrong here I'm not
emotionally chasing or jumping into the
trade just clicking the buy button I am
methodically jumping in but I am
extremely confident in the trade that
things look exactly how I want to when I
enter into a trade and through intuition
I have seen that over time this is my
bread and butter and it has worked
consistently when I'm uncertain or it's
kind of in that gray area between things
don't seem amazing but I think it's good
enough to potentially get into a trade I
try not to force the trade this is a
part of trading that comes down to
really experience and it's hard to deal
with that great area and so generally
when I'm not sure stay out of the trade
and just move on it sucks when you miss
a trade because of that and it worked
out but again there was something
telling you that something was off about
the trade and at the end of the day do
not hindsight trade it's going to ruin
you if you didn't feel something was
right in the moment or it didn't set up
really how you liked but it ended up
working out that doesn't mean it was a
good trade to take now when it comes to
refining your strategy and figuring out
what works for you a huge mistake I see
people making all the time and I did it
myself was having a trading loss and
then trying to figure out what I could
have done better to avoid that loss
entirely or reduce that loss this
naturally makes sense because really
that's how the world works with a lot of
other things but it doesn't work with
trading sometimes a loss can happen and
you didn't do anything wrong the market
can do really anything it wants it
doesn't matter what pattern you saw and
you know the probability that that says
that the Market's going to go a certain
direction you might have gotten the most
perfect looking trade of your life and
it still fails so don't change or tweak
your strategy quickly based on one or
two or even just three losses or trades
that happen you have to give time for
your strategy to play out and to collect
data in your trading journal so later
you can sit down at a calm time when
you're not trading and logically think
about okay what is working and what
isn't and refine your strategy over time
like I did where I eventually realize
okay these things aren't working for me
I only need to focus on taking reversal
trades one mistake I see happening all
the time and I used to do it myself is
I'd see a potential trade come and I'd
not be 100% sure if it was good enough
to get in my confidence wasn't truly
there I'd let the market start to play
out and the market for an example in
this trade the market would start to go
in your favor and right here the market
looks really good that it's probably
going to sell off and keep going lower
and so so then right here I would jump
into the trade now in reality at that
point you're chasing the trade and
really the signal like where I got in
for this trade actually was up here and
so if you're you know the signal should
have been here where you got in but you
wanted to wait for a little bit more
confirmation like this big bearish
Candlestick here well you are waiting a
long time and you're chasing the trade
at that point and if you think about a
risk reward ratio if your stop- loss is
still all the way up here
and then you know you enter in down here
and so you have to wait for the market
to go all the way down here to just get
one times your risk you're making your
risk reward potential way way worse
because you chase that trade you need to
learn to just be confident in your
strategy and if you just missed the
trade because you weren't confident in
it accept it and write that down in your
journal and learn about that for the
next time remember that okay maybe I get
scared and I don't enter in and that's
something I have to work on I miss
trades all the time and it sucks but
chasing trades will ruin you it's going
to make a really bad pattern that will
make it harder for you to be successful
in the long run and this is really your
subconscious not being confident in your
strategy and being too scared to take
that leap into the unknown outcome of a
trade and wanting to really just wait
for that more confidence to be there and
you will never have that in trading
honestly I am nervous every trade I get
into even when it's that trade that that
I'm extremely confident in there's still
nervousness of the unknown outcome now
the biggest thing that I figured out
over my years of trading was how to
trade only 60 to 90 minutes in the
morning I made over $9,400 in the last
30 days trading less than 90 minutes a
day 4 days a week let me show you how I
found entered and managed every trade I
took this month so you can see what it's
exactly like trading this strategy and
how you can execute it yourself
so to show you these all real returns
here's my live ninja Trader account we
go to Performance this month at the end
of the month you can see my gross
realized p&l is a little over
$9,400 and I took one loss it was around
$650 that's generally about how much I
risk per trade and my wins are generally
2 to four times my risk and so over the
month that added up to be a little over
$9,400 and then down here you can see
here is all the trades I took this month
that we're going to go over in this
video every trade I took this month is
going to have something unique about it
that is important to executing this
strategy I will go over my simple trade
entry checklist but trading isn't that
simple there are nuances that you can
only learn by watching how this sets up
on multiple different trades what you'll
notice over all these trades is they're
all pretty much the exact same setup
because what I found is to be successful
at trading you have to make your
strategy almost as simple and consistent
as possible Possible having multiple
strategies and multiple patterns just
didn't work for me and SO trading one
specific strategy made it way more easy
for me to be successful because you're
able to master one thing what we're
looking at is oil Futures you can trade
this strategy on really any Market of
time frame but this is what I personally
trade and so the first thing I do when I
come into trading is we're going to go
over our first trade here you it's
November 1st this is the first trade I
took this month all I did did was I
first looked at the 15-minute chart when
I opened it so what I do is I just like
to look at a larger time frame to find
support and resistance levels pretty
much all I saw was okay there's kind of
a support Zone down here and there's a
pretty clear resistance Zone up here as
well you know the Market's kind of come
up here hit this a couple times did a
pretty big selloff I think that this
selloff right here shows good momentum
and selling pressure from this level up
here and so that's why I wanted to watch
it when I the market came in touch again
what I wanted to look for is this level
coming into today's trade and this is my
zone I drew and so what we're watching
is the recording of me taking this trade
and then once it gets to these levels I
look for a essentially a checklist of
things to show up to get in on a trade
in that first thing is looking for that
really major key support or resistance
level and then of course we just want to
see try and capture the swing lower and
kind of just to preview you can see the
market sold off really nicely off for
that level so let me walk you through
how I actually enter and capture some of
that move and so how I did that was I
kind of just saw okay well it looks like
there is kind of a trend line right here
you can see it it kind of started here
it broke it a tiny bit right here
breaking the the trend line by a couple
candles is not a big deal and then you
can see it bounced here covered up a
little bit by my trade and then it tried
to bounce here by a couple candlesticks
you can see a couple Wicks uh but then
it eventually broke that and so for me
that's a solid reasoning to think that
okay it's it's reversed it's broken
another big thing is looking for a head
and shoulders pattern basically the
market puts a head and shoulders here it
essentially makes a in in its uptrend
you know it's making higher highs it
makes an extreme High here and then it
makes a lower high here and you can see
right here the market does break out of
our resistance zone right here a little
bit but that's okay sometimes it can
break up a little bit but then it can
still realize okay now it's it's going
to go reverse off that level um and then
so the final kind of thing to jump in
just kind of quickly going through this
first trade I want to see a rejection
Candlestick or some kind of engulfing
Candlestick and so that's what happens
right here if I actually just zoom back
in the recording briefly is this is what
I looked to get in on the market kind of
how I see it is the Market's making an
attempt to keep pushing higher here and
I see it as okay the trend's going to
continue higher it's probably going to
push up right here and so what this
Candlestick these kind of two
candlesticks show though is well the
Market's making that attempt and you
know what it's giving up it's it's not
happening and so from there you can see
I pretty much just jump right in on
trade once that candle finishes forming
and then I put my stop above this swing
right here and so that's kind of what I
expect to see if you know if the market
kind of breaks this I just like to get
out and kind of move on and you can see
here kind of zooming forwards again is
the market kind of almost came up here
against me I was kind of down a bunch of
money but when you're trading you have
to just stick with your plan and let
things play out because you know if I
got scared based on this Candlestick
right here and and I just closed up
trying to save a couple hundred hours
and you know I would have missed out on
this massive swing in my favor and so
this kind of really gets starts getting
going in my favor I'm looking at okay
there's kind of a tight downtrend
there's a potential support level and
then I jump into a one minute chart and
you can see there's a really tight
downtrend and so I like to manage my
trades if they get really going in your
favor really rapidly like this I like to
jump out because idea is they can have a
really fast reversal move as well and so
I kind of Trail up my stop based on
breaking this downwards Trend and that
is a really good way to capture the
profits capture the move and then move
on to the next trade so moving on to the
next trade this day was pretty wild I
actually took two trades this day and
they were on new markets that I'm
testing out and so it was a lot of new
things that are really good for
understanding how to trade and move into
different markets and so the first trade
we're looking at was on the euro dollar
on the 9th it's been 9 days 8 days since
I last took a trade and so that's how
the strategy kind of works is you have
to be really patient when you're patient
you can see it pays off really well
right the first thing I do every day
come into the charts look at the
15minute we're looking at the 15-minute
chart of the euro dollar right here and
so just to show you that more is what I
was looking at for that day just drawing
my levels the market had kind of made a
pretty good Zone down here here based on
these these kind of double bottoms and
swings so that's definitely a support
Zone to look at for um but currently the
market was you know market for me opens
up at 630 which is pretty much right
here the market had clear movement the
previous day and overnight I think
creating a solid resistance Zone up here
and so then I would just jump into a 5
minute chart and then see how the market
kind of came up to this level and jump
in based on you know a couple of things
I saw and so to walk you through exactly
how I entered in on that trade we were
at that resistance Zone and you can see
it made a really big breakout of that
level and so what I call this is it's an
exhaustive move or a failed breakout is
the market essentially made an attempt
to break out of this level you know you
have all these people that like to buy
breakouts of Trades if we just look at
the actual five minute chart again is
what they're looking for breakout
Traders are trying to buy this breakout
of this resistance zone right here and
so that's what they're trying to do but
sometimes is the market can do that
it'll break out but then reverse and
fail on them how I do that is I use that
as a confirmation that okay the market
is likely or even more likely to reverse
at this resistance level and I can catch
a big downwards move based on that and
so I actually got in this trade slightly
before this trend had broken and that's
okay sometimes because I had a really
strong Catalyst here and then as well is
if you look at this I there's a really
really strong bearish reversal
Candlestick right here and so I thought
that was a really solid confirmation to
jumping on a trade and bet that the
market was going to reverse here and you
can see that it did start to actually
break that downward Trend as well it
created that lower high that we're
looking for again it's kind of it's a
funky Head and Shoulders but it still
makes that lower high that we're looking
for and so how I actually enter my
trades and figure out how much risk to
take and where to put my stop is
actually have a tool that I take and put
on so if I'm going to enter right here
and I'm going to put my stop right here
above that candles stick I take this
drawing tool that I've made and I have a
fixed set of risk that it tells me that
I need to trade five contracts to hit a
fixed amount of risk and so for me
that's
$600 and so if it shows that if I trade
here based on my stop I will lose
$625 if it goes against me and if I go
you know here here's 1X 2x 3x you'll see
I'll make you know about $1,900 on 3x
and so that's kind of a really helpful
useful tool that I use to know exactly
how to trade and enter each trade
because my stop loss is always a
different amount because it's based on
this Candlestick and so if this
Candlestick is larger or smaller I will
have to trade a different number of
contracts and you see if Ive this if the
Candlestick is smaller to hit that same
risk amount of 650 you have to trade
more contracts and so this is something
I found extremely useful for my trades
that I've made and I pretty much use it
in every trade even though you don't see
it in these recordings all the time
because when it comes of trading it's
extremely important to keep your risk
the same amount across every trade
because you don't want to have a loss be
way larger and take out a ton of wins
and so as that trade played out I
actually was also watching the NASDAQ
futures I watched multiple markets
because it allows me to find more
opportunities and so how I found that is
again just looking at the 15-minute
chart of the NASDAQ futures there's a
pretty clear resistance level up here
and then also there was a pretty good
little support level right here looking
at a 5minute chart I think it it makes
it pretty clear as the market was
clearly bouncing off this level there's
definitely Supply down here there's a
good chance it's going to reverse and so
that's what I was watching as the market
kind of went up and then sold off into
this area around a 7:00 each time and so
I was looking for a potential reversal
higher which you can see happened now
one thing about this one that is kind of
different is the market was really
really choppy at the time and so I had
seen spots where I kind of thought to
get in and so sometimes this will happen
with this strategy is and with any
strategy is you'll see almost false
signals to get in so it's really
important to figure out how to not get
essentially tricked by the market to G
in based on these and so one thing that
the market had done is the market opened
again at 6:30 my time and so what I saw
over here was the market had made a
massive rip up into our actually
resistance level but it never made a
trade setup and then it had a massive
rip down here and when the market does
this usually it can be kind of a signal
that okay there's a lot of momentum
there we actually might break this
support level down here and so what I
took from that is I need to let the
market kind of lose some steam see
what's going on you know there's this
other trade setting up that I'll jump in
on in the euro dollar and so I came back
to this and saw that well the market had
kind of sat here for you know about 40
minutes and so what I saw with this is
jumping in is it had a clear break of
this downtrend and it had started to
lose that momentum and you can see that
we made a basically a higher low right
here what my concern with getting into
this trade was well the markets already
kind of it it's looking really sloppy
and I think there's a lot of downwards
momentum there was a really big bearish
candle right here and right here and
then we started to actually see some
strength and so right here it kind of
made a new high this kind of break move
here I think shows some strength and so
my thinking was okay this right here
these three red candlesticks could be
its final attempt to go lower because of
that that's kind of the final
confirmation that I like to see when
this essentially fails and it had this
really strong green Candlestick here
showing a massive p push higher of
essentially it failing to continue the
trend lower and so because of that the
idea is well if it fails to go lower it
has a higher chance that it's going to
reverse go higher because you know
you're trapping essentially people
people are betting that the Market's
going to go down here and if it doesn't
while they have to get out of their
trade we're just going to push the
market higher I was still a little
nervous with the market being kind of
whips side here sometimes the market
will get into modes like this where it
just kind of gets into a sideways slop
Trend here I kind of wanted a little bit
more confirmation and so if I kind of
Zoom back in the trade so we can see
these candlesticks is I jumped in right
at this green Candlestick right here
because my thought is you can see
there's essentially like a little wedge
right here and so my idea was well okay
it failed this attempt to go down right
here and there's a little attempt to
keep going lower here too this big
bearish Candlestick it's failing that
again and so I think that after this big
green Candlestick right here that's a
really solid confirmation right when I
get in you can see that this red
Candlestick just starts puking lower and
that's when you know you're thinking I'm
an idiot I should have waited for you
know I should have done something else
this was a bad trade you know every time
I get into a trade I'm nervous there's
always that nervousness that you're
going to be wrong or that you're reading
something wrong you know the market has
infinite possibilities and so right now
I'm thinking oh you know I'm watching
these two candlesticks kind of not it's
not working out right away and I'm
thinking why I should have bought up
here on the actual breakout because I
wouldn't even be in this trade right now
and then zooming forwards a little bit
is it it eventually does break out in my
favor and you know using that same tool
I have my entry here with my stop loss
right here and then the idea is that I
jumped in on a trade long and now this
trade is actually on a one minute chart
and so I I really have started to expand
my trades onto multiple charts and
multiple time frames and so that allows
you to find more trades because when it
comes to trading the way to be
profitable is find something that really
really works for you that you can be
very consistent with to increase your
win rate as much as possible but finding
some of those is it doesn't show up very
often you know I only took one trade
this month on some of these markets and
so having multiple markets in play and
multiple time frames allows you to see
this stuff more often once we kind of
had a little bit of a breakout here I
move my stop up here my stop loss with
the IDE idea that I think that again
keeping the idea that we are in this
kind of tight range if the market comes
up to essentially right here and sells
off well I just want to get out of the
trade it's it's not worth trying to deal
with you know oh is it going to come
back and then keep going you know when
the Market's in a sideways pattern and
it's it's just going to sit there and so
it's either going to break out here or
it's more likely to just kind of sit
here and I don't want to deal with that
I want to get out you know take the
scratch essentially take the risk out
the table and move on to a better trade
so I've always found that the best
trades kind of work out like this in
your favor pretty quickly you can see it
started to break out higher and we start
to have almost that exhaustive move in
the flip side you see right here this
big Candlestick kind of triggers in my
mind that okay we're getting up to this
resistance Zone up here it's already
where the market sold off once we're up
about 2 3 times my risk and so I need to
Trail up my stop loss and so right here
this Candlestick kind of pulls back here
reverses and so I elect to tighten up my
trailing stop there's kind of a tight
trend line right here again to manage
that trade more closely essentially you
can see it starts to lose that momentum
and so that's what I'm looking for is
I'm looking to get in when it kind of
loses the momentum of the downtrend
catch the move up and then get out when
it starts to lose the momentum on the
flip side just essentially you're
catching the easy money yeah sometime I
you know you don't capture the the whole
swing but again the idea is you're
capturing 80% of the Swing trying to get
in down here at the lows and then get
out here at the exact highs is really a
way to set yourself up for failure and
then going back to my other euro dollar
trade that I had on at the same time is
I actually went for a walk with my dog
because you can see it's been going for
about 2 hours it's really doing nothing
and you just have to kind of distract
yourself you know it's hard to kind of
just sit there and and watch paint dry
basic basically and so what I did was I
just left my stop where I was I actually
put in a limit order at 3x with the idea
that hey you know if for some reason
while I'm gone this thing just Zips in
my favor and knocks me out at 3x I think
that's a great spot it's kind of down
here where it's probably a support Zone
anyway and at this point I came back
went to break even because I could watch
it and took the profit Target away and
all of a sudden a massive move happened
and I it was because of some news some
massive moves started going in my favor
and to manage this was I actually went
to a one minute chart again because it
was moving so rapidly it was happening
so fast I didn't get a chance to change
my recording but to show you on an
actual chart here is what I did and so
what I saw was the market was breaking
down massively in my favor and I hit
about 3x and so here was my drawing tool
3x was about here and so this trade
actually got to about 4X one thing I
didn't explain earlier was my full size
was six contracts but I elected to trade
three contracts because this was my
first time taking a trade on the euro
dollar on the 5 minute and so I elected
to trade half size when you're doing
something new Don't Go full size take it
easy take it slow trading is always a
process and so once this broke out in my
favor though I elected to do that tight
trailing stop of just previous
Candlestick high and so I got knocked
out right here on this Candlestick and
again you can see the market then made a
quick reversal off that and so I
captured about four times my risk on
that trade because it was about $300 per
trade and that trade it worked out
really really nice now this next trade
was a little more unconventional but it
was still a really really solid learning
win for you to see and so again like I
always do with my trades first thing
coming into a 15-minute chart we're
looking at the S&P 500 futures now and
so November 15th is when I took my next
trade again it's just kind of waiting
for things to align up this day the
market had been in in a really solid
uptrend for a while really not showing
much in terms of levels so that's why it
kind of took a while for something to
set up and so here on the day when I
again just briefly open the charts is at
about 6:30 this is what I'm seeing
there's some kind of crazy big swing off
of here this is usually news before the
Market opens then there's a couple
little bottoms right here that I'm
looking for maybe some kind of Bounce to
set up off of you know you you don't
know what's going to happen until it
happens it's about just how the market
sets up when it comes to those levels
and so so looking at an actual chart
then with those levels as you can see
right here here was that at 530 a lot of
time some news pops one hour before the
actual Market open had a big spike sell
off came to our level this is pre-market
so I still Drew off of these two bounces
for the support Zone down here and then
of course keeping track of this high up
here as well and so then I followed my
general strategy and so there was
something slightly different about this
one and but you know first thing going
through our checklist is looking for
that support Zone we had a support Zone
down here downtrend was broken you can
already kind of see that there's no
really strong momentum down whenever you
have a really strong downwards Trend you
really need to make sure that the
downwards momentum is broken because a
lot of times a massive downwards Trend
will come to a support Zone have a quick
bounce and then just sell off and so
what I like to do in those situations is
kind of wait for it to do this a little
and then capture and move higher and so
that's kind of what I looked for with
this trade is seeing that we were
already kind of in sideways momentum but
we were having good swings it wasn't
super choppy kind of like that last
trade on the NASDAQ you're having good
movement here and so I think this is
plenty of movement to get in a trade and
then either move to break even when it
kind of starts breaking out in your
favor you know there's room to profit
and so that's a big thing to remember
and so we had this little tight
downtrend here that was broken that's
kind of a minor Trend that I like to see
broken
but another thing again is looking at
that Catalyst that I like to see is you
can see we broke the support level here
by kind of a decent amount but it it was
just two candlesticks and so what this
shows me again the market tried to break
here and then there was a lot of buyers
that came in whoever is on the market
side of things really like this level
and the supply and demand pushed the
market up quickly over this Candlestick
you can see this is a really large
Candlestick that's why to me it shows
that okay there's a lot of buying
pressure down here and so it's likely to
make the market push higher but again I
don't like to get in on that signal I
like to use that as a confirmation and
then wait for kind of the signal over
here to show up and so usually again
that's going with the swings and looking
for that kind of head and shoulders and
that kind of set up here but what I did
here was kind of similar to the NASDAQ
trade is going back to showing the
actual entry is what I saw was okay the
market had our nice little reversal
exhaustive move here and then look at
this this just looks like a bull flag
what this pattern is showing is there's
a consolidation right here and once
you've kind of seen the marker you
almost have an intuition of okay I'm
seeing it consolidate here it's had this
you know I'm seeing a lot of reasons why
it could reverse here and so this is
It's almost like it's waiting it's
condensing before it kind of bursts and
breaks out and so that's what I did here
is I got in on the breakout of this
little sideways Trend here as that kind
of final confirmation and then I use my
risk reward indicator to tell me that I
need to trade three contracts of the
NASDAQ to hit that
$600 risk reward because then you know
again I I'll hit my profit Target that I
want up here and then from there like
always it's just about waiting for the
mark to go in your favor not touching it
and then managing as you fit and so what
you can see here is we are kind of
getting there's you know kind of a
resistance trend line here or you know
the market could definitely kind of have
swings here you got to be aware of it it
could sell off here but you can see
there's I would say there's a pretty
clear uptrend right here and so I like
to again use that as a way to manage my
trade and so I haven't moved up to break
even technically here but I mentally
moved up to break even if the trend
comes here and breaks this trend line
I'm going to move my stop loss
up to wherever that is just because you
don't see me move that it doesn't mean
that I'm not going to I'm not actively
really watching this like a hawk
planning to move it if it all of a
sudden breaks against me and so you can
see it starts to again thinking about it
doing that kind of reversal exhaustive
move on the other side and so I Trail my
stop- loss up there expecting that it to
have a very quick reversal and you can
see that at this point it's again we've
caught 80% of that move as the market
comes back really quickly and so I found
those to be really significantly
powerful ways to get out of the trade so
jumping right into our next trade this
is a trade off of the euro dollar again
exact same thing doing here like always
looking at a 15-minute chart seeing that
okay we have a solid swings back and
forth here I think there's a really good
resistance and support level here and so
Market came up here and all I'm looking
for is we got really good room to profit
down here and so this is something
that's really important about this trade
and I haven't really talked about is
looking at this so it came up here and
then we go into a 5minute chart looking
for the trade and so again this is on a
5minute chart of the euro dollar and now
this time I'm actually full size on the
euro dollar I feel confident I've
watched it for a while based on you know
kind of our checklist it's broken that
trend line we're at a level a resistance
level and then it's made you know kind
of that exhaustive move it's you can see
over here that the Market's kind of in a
choppy range and actually if we pull up
the 5-minute chart to kind of look at it
a little bigger you can see that the
market had a really big move from the
lows chop which is kind of what we see
over here and then a a big move higher
and so what I see with this big move
higher is it's kind of that exhaustive
move you know that Catalyst we're
looking for the Market's attempting to
make a breakout here and it's coming up
to into our Zone giving us our signals
that it's going to potentially reverse
and so again all I look for is you know
kind of it to make that lower high here
it gives us I entered in on this really
strong bearish Candlestick here and so
that puts us with the tool again seeing
I I need to trade seven contracts to get
full size and 3X is about here and so I
actually had a limit order again because
I was out for a walk it's about 9:00 I
usually am finished trading about 8:00
but you know if I have a trade on I'm
I'm going to let it do its thing right
while I'm away it start it starts kind
of doing its thing it's looking great
and so the thing I haven't talked about
yet is why this trade is really strong
is well down here is 3x and so again you
always want to with your trades you want
to be getting in them when there is room
to profit a good amount you don't want
to get in to even if it sets up
perfectly and everything looks amazing
if there is a support zone right here
it's not worth the trade you're taking
risk jumping into the trade initially
right here when I jump into the trade it
is not that far for the market to move
against me for me to lose $600 and so
because of that well I need to the
payoff to be at least 3x and so you know
of course I don't hit that every time
because of my management style but I
need the potential in the market to be
there the clearest support level that I
see is down here and so I think because
you know the market moved up here in a
nice swing I think if it's going to go
in my favor I think there's a good
chance it goes here and if we even bring
up the chart looking at kind of the
bigger move that it has the potential it
has the potential to you know go to that
minor support but that's a minor support
level the major one is all the way down
here and so that gives the trade
potential to be even higher you know you
see up here it's come up here and it
moved way lower really fast and so you
don't you know when you're trading you
don't know what the Market's going to do
you just have to jump in on the
opportunity and wait for it to play out
and sometimes you can capture a massive
move like this super easy and you get
you know a 6 7x trade that makes your
year and so that's why over time what
I've learned is when the trade starts to
kind of go in your favor like this the
trade is looking really solid right now
it's gone about 1X in my favor but if I
Trail my stop- loss up too early it can
have a a pullback here the market could
easily come back up here and then puke
lower and what I've done that in the
past where I I Trail up my stop too
tight and I get knocked out of the trade
and I miss out on the massive move and
the reason because of that is when
you're trading it's scary jumping into a
trade you know you take the risk of this
you you put risk on and it's for me it's
in the back of my mind of like okay the
trade could still come all the way
against me and I lose the $300 I'm up or
even the $600 I was up here and then I
lose the $600 that I'm risking on the
trade so I theoretically it feels like a
$1,200 loss not even a $600 loss I don't
know how to say it but that's just a
part of trading and what I've realize is
over time it gets easier to just deal
with that and I think starting out
smaller with your sizing helps with that
too start out small so the the swings in
the money aren't as big it's taking me a
while to get to this size and that's
just a process of trading is slowly
getting better and bigger over time as
you become more comfortable with
everything that's what I've learned is
is leave it be you know if this is a
solid level and it's going to reverse it
might come up here again but overall
it's going to reverse in your favor and
you see right here is it started to go
against me but after this you know this
is an a perfect example where this has
happened to me is I have jumped out at
break even here and you can see the
Market's kind come up here and it's made
I think a really solid looking reversal
here that has the potential to keep
going lower now that's the thing when
you're managing an in a trade you're
going to be reading into all these
little things and trying to to you know
make ideas of what might happen try and
not do that try and just let it be keep
your hands off the keyboard go for a
walk like I do Leave the Room walk
around in circles you know sit on your
hands because you have to just let
things play out and of course every
trade isn't going to work out I actually
end up losing this trade and just
looking at the f- minute chart you can
see the market had a massive breakout
higher from this resistance level and
that's totally okay you're not going to
magically catch the reversal every time
and it'll work out this is why having
that risk reward in your favor every
time is really really important so that
when you are wrong it's not that big of
a deal it doesn't hit your results that
much and then when you're right it puts
you in the right direction really really
favorably and so one thing I haven't
really talked about yet is combining the
time frames of the 1 minute and the 5
minute or whatever time frame you're
using to help confirm these trade
entries this trade does a really good
show of that and so what we're looking
at is oil Futures and so again as always
15minute chart is the first thing I look
at and you can see right here coming
into the first thing of the day kind of
7:00 a.m. 6:30 a.m. I'm just looking at
okay where are the levels there's a high
right here there's kind of the market
had a sell off here and it's kind of
come down to here bottom two times and
then there's been some swinging in back
and forth here and so that's where I
just kind of draw these levels off of
and so what we're looking for is the
market came down to
this support level right here and then I
went from there into the one minute
chart we have right here and I looked
for reasons why this could reverse and
so the one thing about this trade was if
we look at a 5-minute chart of oil is
the market was really back and forth and
so when the market gets like that and
you can see it's really choppy it'll
sell off but come and come back up and
so the idea is well is there that risk
reward ratio that we're looking for is
there the potential in the market to
have a greater move in the direction
quickly that we can easily capture and
reduce our risk with a smaller you know
tighter stop loss that we can get in
usually I've been trading oil on a
5-minute chart and if I try to jump in
on a long down here and you know set my
profit Target of 3x up here it barely
makes it so it does make it but it's a
lot harder to kind of get that risk
properly and so what I decided to do was
go in to a 1 minute chart I think that
allows me to have a more accurate entry
that's the whole idea of the smaller
time Fram is it allows you to get a more
accurate entry and then I'm sure at this
point you know we were at a support
level we're looking for that downtrend
of slow momentum what I saw for the
biggest reasons that the momentum was
slowing down which is kind of a little
interesting here is look at this
Candlestick right here we had some big
candlesticks right here and then there's
this massive massive Candlestick going
on right here and then uh it reverses
and kind of goes back to lows here and
then we go into sideways chop and then
we had a breakout candle stick right
here and so one thing is what I used to
do is I would see this breakout candle
here forming it looks like a massive
green Candlestick and this is why I
don't jump in Long based on the break of
that trend line I like to wait for it to
make you know the the signals that we're
looking for over here and we'll talk
about it in a second because if you jump
in right here well sometimes it'll
happen it it'll work out but a lot of
the time it's you're jumping in based
off of fomo you're jumping in you know
because of a couple things you see but
you haven't really waited for the signal
you know it's more of a reactionary
trade entry there's a lot of funky
market movement going on right here I
think maybe there's momentum to keep
pushing lower and so one thing I like to
look for is almost that final attempt
for the market to break lower
essentially that failed breakout that
attempt where it really attempts to go
lower and then it reverses essentially
trapping people or baiting people to oh
the Market's going to break out here
they get excited you know they jump in
it really dries up the sellers in the
market because they all jump in and then
it reverses and makes a really really
strong potential for there to be an
immedately flip in the market and so to
show you that form in real time is here
I'm just watching waiting for the market
it's kind of looking good and all of a
sudden we have a massive momentum push
lower with this Candlestick it's turning
red it's attempting to break lower and
then you can see it immedately flips
here and goes higher and so for me
that's it's it's doing that bait and
switch to where I think okay that's a
really good show of it tried to go down
there was a momentum to go down and then
it shows a massive switching momentum of
the market going higher and then from
there I jump in I use my tool to tell me
okay I need to get certain amount of
contracts based on my risk and actually
my tool said I needed to do four
contracts and I accidentally entered in
on five and so I was actually slightly
larger size on this trade and so that
adds to the intensity and this trade
happened really quickly because it's on
a 1 minute chart and so while this is
happening it's pretty intense for me I
don't know what you do while you're in a
trade but when I'm in a trade and I'm
just kind of waiting for it to play out
it's kind of nerve-wracking and so what
I do a lot of time is I you know walk
right in circles around my room talk out
loud essentially of what I'm nervous
about and why I want to get out
essentially talking through the emotions
that I'm feeling because I don't want to
jump out because I'm scared and so what
I did was you know I I just talk through
that and say know you know I'm following
my strategy that's what I'm doing and so
because I was already up 3x on this
trade and I was a little larger size I
eled to actually close out pretty much
when this next Candlestick closed
because this is a large Candlestick you
can see we essentially have an
exhaustive move it's a lot to wait for
it to come back to that trend line here
because you can see if I waited for it
to break this trend line I would have
given up a probably about half of those
profits and that is not something I was
looking to do it had made the Mover look
looking for you know take the easy money
and kind of get out so now let's move on
today and the biggest trade that I took
this month and it took my month to
another level because I made an insane
amount of money on this trade this trade
really shows you the power of the
strategy because most of the time I do
get 2 to 3x my trades but other times I
can get four five six I think I've even
got up to a 7x trade and so that's where
you can make a ton of money in one trade
and now those don't happen very often
but but when they do they can make your
month or your year what actually
happened today was we're looking at a
chart of the es Futures right now and
you can see right there I actually had
an order put in we're at a support level
there's a really nice double bottom here
with a strong Candlestick and I put in a
buy order uh the market was kind of
being a little crazy and so I missed out
on a trade here it was frustrating
because if we look at it it it went
really well in my favor and so I was a
little frustrated over that foam
yesterday actually the market had a lot
of movement and I wasn't able to capture
any of it because none of it set up and
so today I you know talking a little bit
more about the emotions of trading is I
was a little frustrated and feeling fomo
5 minutes later you can see that it
worked very well it would have been a
good entry and you know I'm kind of
kicking myself a little bit and what I
did was I refocused and said you know
what there are other things going on in
the market I am looking at oil and I'm
looking at you know other markets and
right here just zooming forwards in that
recording a little bit I switched to
taking a trade in oil because there was
another potential opportunity and so you
have to try and reset or or deal with
your emotions when you're getting
frustrated because if we just kind of
look at this entry here is if I actually
pull up the 15-minute chart of oil for
this to show you where that level was
and so the market this is kind of a
really far level I don't normally go
this far back in levels but you can see
that there was a a very high up here
where the market had sold off of and
it's been like 2 weeks before we've come
up there again and so zooming into today
the market had come up there sold off
and it had kind of been a little choppy
uh and then we had kind of a spike up
into it going actually to a smaller time
frame chart to show that a little better
the market had spiked up into that level
sold off you know a little fomo even off
of this move being like dang that's a
sweet move I wish I caught that um and
then seeing the market come up here
again and remembering hey just be
patient wait for the thing to come to
you um and you know wait for a setup and
so got in based on the market had kind
of chugged up here a nice movement and
then you can see our classic exhaustive
move this Candlestick right here is
massive out of nowhere right into our
our level and so what happened was I
figured okay that looks like it's doing
a kind of climactic move it had a little
bit of a selloff pullback to that like
always I want to wait for that lower
high or some kind of retest and pullback
that the market does because I want to
see the market well you know maybe the
trend keeps going here and you can see
it's still it's still kind of in our
trend line you know it's not a clear
break and then right here it set up a an
actually good looking canle for this and
so because of that you know looking it
made kind of a nice double top and so I
didn't actually get in on this candles
stick right here because it's kind of
small and so what I did instead was the
second candle after it it was a pretty
good bearish candle and so I thought
okay these two candles combined show I
would say you know a Candlestick that
looks like this it's kind of a a pretty
big bearish candle and I want to jump in
at the break low of that Candlestick so
this isn't the normal style that I get
in all the time a lot of time I like to
wait for the one Candlestick um but this
one I I kind of waited saw that okay
well maybe it comes here maybe it you
know goes up here and keeps going but
you know once it kind of broke this I
think that was a solid kind of entry and
and from there well things went pretty
well pretty quickly there was news
coming out at around this time I knew
about um and so once the kind of Market
moved down to here I moved to break even
just in case there was some crazy news
that switched the market against me um
and just you know made a massive candle
I don't I don't want to turn this into a
loss right um but then once we got down
here this is about 3x you know $1,800 is
3x and so I'm thinking okay again I
don't want that news to come back on me
I want to ratchet up my stop and get
these profits you know it's it's the end
of the month I I want to just add on to
my month you know there's there's
definitely in the back of my mind I'm
still thinking of results even though I
try and remove them from my screen and
as much as possible not think about them
and then you know from here I'm looking
at okay there's previous Candlestick
that's what we're looking at this starts
to move insanely fast and so this is
where the news pops and you can see that
the market goes crazy and so I'm
thinking okay what do I do here and so
to manage this I'm thinking that okay I
can't wait for the market to pull back
on me like this you have to tighten up
way more than normal usually I have it
you know a previous Candlestick trailing
stop or like middle of the bar but this
bar right here is like $1,500 worth of
movement um and so there's no reason to
let the market move that far back on you
at some point you do have to think about
the money and you just have to close out
because this is some crazy news sure
there is the potential for to pull back
and keep going even more but don't get
greedy take the easy money and just move
on with your day if you want to start
making $500 or more a day trading there
are two negative trading Loops that you
have to be aware of and break out of if
you don't you'll be stuck struggling at
trading for years I see it constantly
myself included was stuck in these two
loops and there are the whole reason you
are probably right now jumping from
strategy to strategy trying to be
consistently profitable and so I want to
walk you through what these two Loops
are and how you can break out of them to
eventually becoming consistently
profitable the whole journey of becoming
a consistent Trader is a struggle in the
beginning where you are generally just
consistently losing or just not making
any money and once you actually break
out of these Loops your Equity curve and
profitability will go from flatlining to
losing to consistently profitable this
is the whole goal that all of us as
Traders want and so let me walk you
through what these are and how you can
break out of them and so I look at
trading as there are three stages of
becoming profitable and and the first
stage is that you are stuck in what is
called a learning Loop and so how this
works is you come in trading you know
you first start you find a strategy you
like and you start testing it out and so
you do this for a couple weeks couple
months you know you have some success
but eventually you start to become not
consistently profitable with it and so
you stop getting good results or you're
just not getting the results you want
and so then of course like logically
with anything else in life you look to
go back and learn more cuz generally
with anything in life is if you learn
more you become better at it so you
either look to find a new strategy or
you look to add either different
Candlestick patterns or other indicators
to the strategy and so then again you
start to test that out but lo and behold
you aren't getting the results you want
and so you go back to the drawing board
of either scrapping everything trying to
find new strategy or adding new things
to it and so you get stuck in this cycle
I was stuck in this cycle for years
jumping from strategy to strategy
because I didn't find something that
worked for me but I also didn't stop
myself from being stuck in this cycle
and so we're going to talk about how you
can break out of this but first I want
to talk about the second Loop that you
can get stuck in because once you break
out of this you're going to go right
into another trap that I call the self
sabotage Loop once you learn more about
trading you'll start to realize that
there are a lot of emotions in it
especially when you start trading real
money things can get very intense you
can get emotional you can start foming
into the trades getting nervous
frustrated impulsivity comes in your
trading and so there is this whole web
of emotions that negatively impact your
trading and so all of these different
feelings greed Euphoria desperate ation
they make it so you are self sabotaging
your trading and so let me illustrate
what this can look like and what my
self-sabotage Loop look like because you
will start to see how this Cycle Works
and how it self-sabotaged me and will
give you insight to what yours might
look like and so for me my biggest issue
with trading was I had the fear of being
wrong I was scared of a trade losing
losing money during that trade and so
anytime that I would see a potential
opportunity come whatever strategy I was
trading I would start to get nervous
when the time came to enter and so I
that fear would come in and take control
of me and so then I would skip the trade
and of course generally because I'm
following a strategy that works most of
the time that would work out that trade
would have worked out and I would have
been able to make a profitable trade and
so instead because I skipped out on that
trade I became frustrated because I
missed out on the money I could have
made from that trade which was
frustrating and so that frustration
would stay with me as I'm still watching
the charts and what it would do is I
would be sitting there waiting for
another trade opportunity to come and
something would kind of start to set up
but let's say if I have a checklist you
know of five things I'm looking for to
jump into a trade three out of five of
them would up and I would say you know
what this is good enough I'm going to
jump in because I don't want to miss out
on this trade because I did that just
for the last one and it worked out and
so I fomed into a trade now because I
was frustrated and it allowed my
emotions to can take control of me and
so from there generally because I'm
jumping in on a bad trade now based on
fomo is it would turn into a loss and I
would become even more frustrated and
sometimes this would turn into something
even worse tunnel vision Panic you know
I would start to Revenge trade even and
I would take more losses but eventually
I would get to a point where I say okay
I have to take a break I got to be done
with trading for the day I need to
either take tomorrow off or you know
somehow reset and come back to the
drawing board right and of course I
would reset but those emotions and
underlying reasons of why I you know had
the fear of being wrong would restart
and this cycle would just continue and
so that would be how I would be stuck in
I still broke out of the learning Loop
but now I'm stuck in another loop of
just self- sabotaging myself over and
over and this is something I constantly
see other people struggling with they'll
have a strategy but they'll have all
these emotions that are just negatively
impacting their trading and if we don't
learn how to deal with these and stop
them from controlling our actions we're
never going to get to the end goal of
becoming consistently profitable and so
I want to walk through how we can combat
these three stages how we can go from
being stuck in the learning Loop to
being in the self-sabotage Loop and
breaking out of both of those to become
consistently profitable and I'm
confident that I know what I have will
help you because I've heard it from
other people that they were jumping from
strategy to strategy until they learned
some of the stuff I'm about to teach you
and it helped them break out of those
loops and become consistently profitable
and so let's first work on how we can
break out of the learning Loop because
that's generally the one that I think
stops the most people and so the first
thing with doing that is you have to
find a strategy that works for you and
so my strategy is super simple over time
I realized that you know through all the
strategies I was trying out all I could
really be confident in that hey I know
how to find clear support or resistance
zones and I can see that the market can
clearly bounce off those levels and so I
created a strategy based on that all
this does is it's a simple process of I
wait for the market to come down to one
of these levels and then I look for on a
smaller time frame chart generally I
trade on a one minute chart and then I
essentially follow my step pattern and
then step two is waiting for you know
kind of the current Trend to come down
and then step three is I look for kind
of reversal pattern and then I jump in
betting that the market is going to go
higher and I usually go for you know a
three times risk reward ratio so if I'm
risking something like $150 here I'll
eventually manage the trade and you know
here I made about $600 on a trade so it
was about a 4X tradeing so that was a
really nice profit and so this isn't
something I'm going to go into a ton of
detail here because I have a ton of
YouTube videos explaining this but the
whole idea is that you need to narrow
down your focus and so for me that's
what looking solely at reversal patterns
did is instead of trying to you know
catch every swing in the market of okay
I'm going to catch a reversal here I'm
going to look for a continuation trade
up here instead I'm just looking for one
specific thing every day and that's all
I do what I've realized as well is
because all I do is I really just look
at the Candlestick patterns I use just a
couple of trend lines you know support
and resistance zones that it simplifies
things really well and it allows you to
actually trade this on really any Market
or time frame because these Candlestick
patterns are just a reflection of the
price and what the market is doing and
so this can apply to any market and one
thing that narrowed this down even more
for me and I've always found that to get
out of that learning Loop the better
thing to do is take things away what can
you do that will take away things that
are negatively impacting your trading if
if trading you know three different
patterns is negatively impacting your
trading take out one or two that you
don't feel like you're consistently as
profitable with and so another thing
that really helped me narrow things down
over time was looking at kind of 30
minute reversals is what I realized is
just consistently looking at the market
is looking at the NASDAQ futures and the
S&P 500 futures is 30 minutes after the
open if on these charts The Market opens
at 6:30 which is West Coast time it's 30
minutes around 7:00 is that's when the
markets reverse a lot and so that's how
I narrow down my focus even more and
stuck with a really solid strategy so I
you know don't don't go back in that
learning Loop you got to be aware these
Loops once you break out of it you can
go right back into it if you're not
careful and so that's something I've
always working towards is just getting
better and and more narrow focuses every
chart of these These are from one one
specific month and you can see at 7:00
there's a really nice The Market opens
kind of moves down makes a really nice
double bottom and then reverses and so
this is something that I find that is
super repeatable and that this is how
you want to approach trading is find
something that you are confident in and
that you can consistently do day in and
day out because if you spend your time
trying to just jump around and you know
react to the what the market is doing
instead of going in and having a plan
you're not going to become consistently
profitable and so that's something that
I have found to be really beneficial and
another really cool tool that I actually
made I call the news Navigator is when
you're trading Futures and the S SMP 500
is that well there's a lot of news that
comes out and so just to quickly Show
You Is Here is a news release platform I
use it's just called Forex Factory and
it just shows every day okay there is
news releases that are either red and
you got to be really aware of or there's
just yellow ones that aren't a big deal
or some orange ones and what I realized
is this doesn't actually do a good job
of saying what is important or not and
so what I did is I just looked at you
know every release and took data over
time of saying okay what's the release
what's the potential movement and so is
there actually potential movement and so
can I trade through the release and so
there's not many that happened 15
minutes after the market open opens but
there's a ton that happen an hour before
the Market opens and 30 minutes after
the Market opens and so this 30 minute
one that happens after the market open
these ones are really important to pay
attention to because there's some that
you got to be aware of that cause
massive movement and some that are just
no movement at all and you can trade
through and so that is something that I
found really really helpful with just
narrowing my focus down even more and so
that's really how you have to break out
of that learning Loop is find something
that you like like and stick to it it
doesn't have to be my strategy we all
have different trading personalities and
what you know makes sense for us and
what we feel comfortable with I feel
comfortable with taking reversal trades
because that's what I just mentally
makes sense I can see that okay when the
market comes down for me I see that okay
there's a good risk reward here and that
makes a lot of sense for me versus some
people they're just better at
continuation trades but for me mentally
that just doesn't work and so the second
thing is once you break out of that
you're going to be put right into the
self-sabotage Loop and so there's four
steps to breaking out of this Loop and
so the important ones are is building
awareness of what your emotions are that
negatively impact your trading you know
my big ones were you know the fear of
being wrong and so starting to become
aware of just what those are the
frustration of missing profits maybe
yours is fomo maybe yours is greed or
desperation to you know make a lot of
money quickly and so you have to then
once you become aware of what those
emotions are you got to understand how
you react impulsively to those actions
and so for me you know my fear of being
wrong would lead me to skip a trade and
that I don't necessarily want to
logically skip a trade I want to
logically be following my plan but as
humans we follow our emotions a lot
we're emotional beings they take control
over us and impulsively cause us to do
things and so a lot of the time is we
are reactionary based on our emotions
and what we need to learn to do is we
need to overcome our impulsivity to
react to those emotions and so instead
we want to react how we want and so
instead what a really good way to
illustrate this is I still when a trade
comes up I still have that innate fear
of being wrong and so I get nervous and
instead of skipping a trade out of that
fear I have created a new pattern and a
way I react instead of reacting based on
my emotions and my fear I say no I want
to jump into this trade and so when I
would jump into that trade it would
break that self-sabotage Loop and it
would start this new Loop of I jump in a
trade and I would start to build
confidence in my ability to trade and so
then it would come up to the next trade
and I would still have that same emotion
of being fearing fear of being wrong but
instead I've now started to learn to
control those actions and I consistently
react accordingly and how I want to and
so that's the biggest thing to help
break yourself out of that Loop is
instead of letting your emotions control
you you feel your emotions except that
you feel that way it's okay to be scared
that you're going to be wrong we're not
robots it's a part of who we are and
instead you just say okay I feel that
way but I'm still going to do what I
want to do and so this is the basic
framework of breaking out of that
learning Loop breaking out of the
self-sabotage Loop and becoming
consistently profitable now just because
you know this doesn't mean it's not
going to be easy it's still going to be
really hard and so what I've done to
help accelerate this for you is I've
created a 90day confident Trader program
that is designed to help you break out
of both of these loops and become
consistently profitable as fast as
possible and I'm confident that this
will help you drastically accelerate and
improve your trading because I've seen
it do that for people already people
that have were struggling for so long
they were losing and just consistently
you know in that part of the learning
curve where they're just not making
consistent money and then they join the
program and they start to see that
change in their Equity curve where
they're consistently profitable month
after month and it's just awesome to see
where these people are saying you know
they've been struggling and not
consistent for three and a half years
and they're way more consistent than
ever you know they feel like they
finally found their strategy if they're
using my reversal strategy but it's also
helping them just break those cycles
that you're just stuck in as a Trader
and there have been people that have had
big 50% account returns after a year
this person down here almost has 100%
return and so what I want this to
illustrate is that it's helped a lot of
other people break out of these learning
loops I can never you know guarantee
that you are going to make 90 $6,000 in
2 months but I can guarantee that this
is going to drastically accelerate your
learning curve and your process getting
through these loops and so let me
illustrate to you how this program is
laid out and how it's going to help you
break out of the learning Loop and then
the self-sabotage Loop and so first is
right away when you jump in is you are
going to get access to my whole trading
strategy and everything I have and know
about what makes a profitable strategy
and how to become consistently with it
and manage and grow an account over time
and keeping you out of being stuck in
that cycle and so the first thing that
it's going to address is it's just going
to jump start your trading Journey it's
going to help you build your foundation
of how to understand everything that I'm
talking about going forwards but then
it's going to walk you through how to
consistently look for reversals because
again that's what my strategy focuses on
it's going to give you a deep dive into
to how I identify those patterns the
early shifts that the market has and
teach you Advanced market movement that
will help you realize when these signals
are going to happen and so this dives
into way more depth than what my YouTube
videos do those really give a good
overview of my entry checklist and how I
trade but this gives you a super deep
dive into everything about that and then
as well it'll start to go into how to
consistently manage trades it'll go into
my road map of those 30 minute after the
market open reversals it'll give you
that news release navigator that we
talked about and it will just go through
I have hours and months of trade
examples in there and the biggest thing
about this is probably it helps you know
when to avoid entering trades even when
the signal shows up because what I see a
lot of people doing is they will follow
my five-step checklist but there's times
when you actually shouldn't be entering
in the trade and there's certain signals
that show that and then the last really
crucial thing is learning how to grow
your account and treat trading like a
business I have a three-step sizing
growth plan in there that will really
help you know how to scale properly and
go at this the right way the biggest
thing about trading and breaking that
learning Loop is you need to become
process focused and focus on on
consistently executing the same strategy
because otherwise you're just going to
be stuck in this learning Loop over and
over and so all this will help you break
out of that learning Loop and then we go
on to the second part of the program
which is really where the 90 days comes
in I have a 9 week framework that is
going to now start focusing on that
self- sabotage Loop and instead of you
getting stuck in that it's going to help
you break out of that and work towards
becoming consistently profitable with
your strategy what this is going to do
is it's going to be giving you weekly
actionable steps and systems that you
can use to start becoming aware of how
things are negatively affecting you it's
going to help you build your emotional
Matrix and figure out what's actually
affecting you the level that it's
affecting you and how you can actually
change how these negatively affect you
and then as well it's going to start to
bring in some other concept of your
mental capital and your body battery and
how do you can deal with LW streaks and
change those around there are a ton of
destructive emotions that affect your
trading and you need to learn how to
control them and so what this is going
to do is there are Frameworks in there
that I call the stimulus Gap response
framework that is going to stop you from
becoming impulsive and you want it'll
help you react how you want I have
another really really cool system in in
there that I call the emotional spectrum
that is going to help you stay calm amid
all the chaos and help you know okay
what emotions am I okay to trade during
and when I feel certain emotions what do
I do and how do I stay away from
starting to Revenge trade and get out of
control and then the last whole phase of
this is how you start to work to
becoming consistently profitable how you
start narrowing things down stopping the
Lost stre and the boom and bus cycles
that really start to happen when you
start to get close to becoming
profitable and then as well what it'll
start do is it'll start to ingrain these
things into muscle memory so instead of
having that self-sabotage Loop be you
know a negative pattern you're going to
break out of that and you're going to
start to make positive patterns and
Loops that you are stuck in that are
beneficial to your training and so
essentially successful trading will
start to become like muscle memory for
you that's what's so powerful about this
is you are think of everything like
muscle memory all our how we react to
things and how this self-sabotage Loop
works is it's just muscle memory your
body is used to saying okay I'm nervous
I'm scared I'm going to stay away from
and get away from what is making me
nervous and scared and not do whatever
that thing is and instead we reprogram
our minds and create different Pathways
and muscle memory to create positive
emotions Loops that positively affect
our trading and so all of this you can
find in my self-paced on demand 90
confident Trader program and you can get
that in the link below and for a short
time actually this is going to be on
sale it's going to be $100 off as is
Black Friday and there's actually only
going to be aund spots available for
that and so really what you get access
with this is everything that I have
built out that is going to help you
break out out of that learning Loop and
then into the self- sabotage Loop and
break out of that and accelerate your
trading to becoming consistently
profitable and so there are a there's
hours and hours on my strategy and how
to consistently execute that because you
know that's one of the most important
things but then you also have that nine
weeks of your trading mindset focused
work you're going to get lifetime access
to all this you're going to get a ton of
tools guides
routines and as well as Frameworks to
help build your trading career you're
going to get that news release navigator
that I talked about earlier and as well
there's a couple of things I've added in
as exclusive bonuses I've added in
lifetime community access to my
exclusive trading chat room and
generally this is a monthly subscription
and so it's going to save you a ton of
money for that but as well this is
really helpful in once you've gone
through this whole program and used all
these tools gone through those 90 days
you're still going to want continued
help and education and what this
community does is it's an extremely
active community that helps each other
and not just for me but everyone else
there is focus on the same thing and
they're going to know all these
materials that you're working on too and
so it's going to help you bounce ideas
off of each other and as well off of me
and get help anytime you need another
thing that added is I have learned a ton
about the mental side of trading from my
actual trading coach he focuses mainly
on the mental side of trading with me
and what we did is we sat down for an
hour and a half session and talked about
what it will take for someone starting
with this strategy he knows this
strategy very well cuz I've worked with
him for coming up on 4 years now is how
we can tailor all of this and best make
it work for you someone coming from a
beginner or you know stuck in those
loops and how they can start to break
them going forward and so this is an
hour and a half session that is highly
focused on that and I think you will
find it insanely beneficial to have
someone else's perspective as well on
all this and then the last thing is
because I'm so confident in this program
drastically improving and changing your
trading just from how much effort I've
put into it but also just reviews from
other people is that I have 100%
guarantee to give you a refund no
questions asked in the first 30 days if
you for any reason it doesn't matter
want a refund just email me and I will
happily give it to you the idea is this
is you know I understand there's a lot
of shady stuff out there online and I
just want to make this kind of a
risk-free investment for you to help
accelerate your journey and trading by
saving you a lot of time but also saving
you a lot of money I lost a lot of money
making a ton of mistakes and trying to
break out of these Loops myself and so
what this is going to do is it's going
to help you do that for less money and
less time and so I highly recommend
checking out the link below it'll go
into way more in depth and show you kind
of everything that's in the platform
more than I've talked to here and of
course you don't have to get the program
we talked about ways for you to break
out of the learning Loop and the
self-sabotage Loop already and so feel
free to keep going about it on your own
if you want and if that works for you if
not though I'll see you inside